the following is a conversation with
matt walker sleep scientist professor of
neuroscience and psychology at berkeley
author of why we sleep and the host of a
new podcast called the matt walker
podcast
it's 10 minute episodes a couple of
times a month covering sleep and other
health and science topics
i love it and recommend it highly it's
up there with the greats like the
hubermann lab podcast with andrew
huberman and i think david sinclair is
putting out an audio series soon too i
can't wait to listen to it i'm really
excited by the future of science in the
podcasting world
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors stamps.com squarespace
athletic greens better help and on it
their links are in the description
as a side note let me say that to me a
healthy life is one in which you fall in
love with the world around you with
ideas with people
with small goals and big goals no matter
how difficult with dreams you hold on to
and chase for years
life should be lived fully
that to me is the priority that to me is
a healthy life second to that is the
understanding and the utilization of the
best available science on diet exercise
supplements
sleep and other lifestyle choices to me
science in the realm of health is a
guide for we should try not the absolute
truth of how to live life
the goal is to learn to listen to your
body and figure out what works best for
you
all that said a good night's sleep can
be a great tool in making life awesome
and productive and matt is a great
advocate of the how and the why of sleep
we agree on some things and disagree on
others but he's a great human being a
great scientist and as of recently a
friend
with whom i enjoy having these wide
ranging conversations
this is the lex friedman podcast and
here is my conversation with matt walker
you should try these shades on and see
what you look like
so they are now your shades
and that's not the question it's the
same thing as uh putin took the super
bowl ring and it's now his ring
[Laughter]
yeah one wonders if he was offered it
but um they are yours
[Laughter]
when did you first
fall in love with the
dream of understanding sleep like
where did the fascination with sleep
begin
so
back in the united kingdom you can sort
of start doing medicine at age 18 and
it's a five-year program and i was at
the queen's medical center in the uk
and i remember just being fascinated by
states of consciousness and particularly
anesthesia
i was thinking
isn't that within seconds i can take a
perfectly conscious human being
and i can remove
all existence of the mentality and their
awareness within seconds
and that stunned me so i started to get
really interested in conscious states i
even started to read a lot about
hypnosis
and all of these things hypnosis
even sleep and dreams at the time they
were very esoteric it was sort of
charlatan science at that stage
and i think almost all of my colleagues
and i are accidental sleep researchers
you know no one as i recall in the
classroom when you're sort of five years
old and the teacher says what would you
like to be when you grow up you know no
one's putting their hand up and saying i
would love to be a sleep researcher
and so when i was doing my phd
i was trying to
identify different forms of dementia
very early on in the course
and i was using electrical brainwave
recordings to do that and i was failing
miserably it was a disaster just no
result after no result
and i used to go home to the doctor's
residence with this sort of little igloo
of journals that at the weekend i would
sort of sit in and uh and read and which
i'm now thinking do i really want to
admit this because it sounds like i had
no social life which i didn't i'm a
social leper but
and i started to realize that some parts
of the brain were
um sleep-related areas and
some dementias were eating away those
sleep-related areas other dementias
would leave them untouched and i thought
well
i'm doing this all wrong i'm measuring
my patients while they're awake
instead i should be measuring them while
they're asleep started doing that got
some amazing results
and then i wanted to ask the question is
that sleep
disruption that my patients are
experiencing as they go into dementia
maybe it's not a symptom of the dementia
i wonder if it's a cause of
the dementia
and at that point which was
kafka 20 years ago um
no one could answer a very simple
fundamental question why do we sleep
and
i at the time didn't realize that some
of the most brilliant minds in
scientific history had tried to answer
that question and failed
and at that point i just thought well
i'm going to go and do a couple of years
of sleep research and i'll figure out
why we sleep and then i'll come back to
my patients in this question of dementia
and as i said that was 20 years ago and
what i realized is that hard questions
occur very little about who asks them
they will meter out their lessons of
difficulty all the same and i was
schooled
in the difficulty of the question why do
we sleep
but in truth 20 years later we've had to
upend the question
rather than saying why do we sleep and
by the way the answer then was that we
sleep to cure sleepiness
which is like saying all right you know
we eat to cure hunger yeah that tells
you nothing about the physiological
benefits of food same with sleep
now we've actually have to ask the
question is there any physiological
system in the body or any major
operation of the mind that isn't
wonderfully enhanced when we get sleep
or demonstrably impaired when we don't
get enough
and so far for the most part the answer
seems to be now
so far the answer seems to be no
so why
why does the body and the mind
crave sleep then why do we sleep
how you know
can we begin to answer that question
then
so i think one of the ways that i think
about this or
one of the answers that came to me
is the following the reason that we
implode so quickly and so thoroughly
with insufficient sleep is because human
beings seem to be one of the few species
that will deliberately deprive
themselves of sleep for no apparent good
reason biological
and what that led me then to was the
following
mother nature as a consequence so no
other species does what we do in that
context there are a few species that do
undergo sleep deprivation but for very
obvious clear biological reasons one is
when they're in a condition of severe
starvation the second is when they're
caring for their newborn so for example
killer whales will often deprive
themselves the female will go away from
the pod
give birth and then bring the calf back
and during that time the mother will
undergo sleep deprivation
and then the the third one is during
migration when birds are flying trans
oceanographic to 3 000 miles but for the
most part it's never seen in the animal
kingdom
which brings me back to the point
therefore mother nature
in the course of evolution has never had
to face the challenge of this thing
called sleep deprivation
and therefore she has never created a
safety net in place
to
circumnavigate this common influence
and
there's a good example where we have
which is called the adipose cell the fat
cell
because during our evolutionary past we
had famine and we had feast and mother
nature came up with a very clever recipe
which is
how can i store caloric
credit so that i can spend it when i go
into debt and the fat cell was born
brilliant idea where is the fat cell for
sleep
where is that sort of banking chip for
sleeping unfortunately we don't seem to
have one because she's never had to face
that challenge so even if there's not
some kind of physics
fundamental need for sleep
that uh physiologically or
psychologically the the fact is most
organisms are built such that they need
it and then mother nature
never built an extra mechanism for sleep
deprivation so it's interesting that
why we sleep by not have a good answer
but we need to sleep to be healthy
is nevertheless true yeah and we have
many answers right now in some ways the
question of why we sleep was the wrong
question too
it's you know what are the pluripotent
many reasons we sleep we don't just
sleep for one reason
because
from an evolutionary perspective it is
the most idiotic thing that you could
imagine yeah you know when you're
sleeping you're not
finding a mate you're not reproducing
you're not caring for your young you're
not foraging for food and worse still
you're vulnerable to predation
so on any one of those grounds
especially as a collective
sleep should have been strongly selected
against in the course of evolution
but in every species that we've studied
carefully to date sleep is present
yeah so it is important so like
you're right i think i've heard
arguments from an evolutionary biology
perspective that sleep is actually
advantageous
you know maybe like some kind of
predator predator-prey relationships
yeah but you're saying it actually makes
way more sense what you're saying
is it should have been selected against
like why close your eyes
yeah why because and you know there was
an energy conservation hypothesis for a
while which is that we need to
essentially go into low battery mode you
know power down because it's
unsustainable but in fact that actually
has been blasted out the water because
sleep is an incredibly active process in
fact the difference between you just
lying on the couch but remaining
conscious versus you lying on the couch
and falling asleep it's only a savings
of about 140 150 calories in other words
you know you just go out and club
another baby seal or whatever it was and
you wouldn't worry you know so it has to
be much more to it than energy
conservation much more to it than
sharing you know ecosystem space and
time much more to it than simply
predator prey relationships
if sleep really did and
you know looking back even very old
evolutionary organisms like earthworms
millions of years old they have periods
where they're active in periods where
they're passively asleep it's called
lethargics
and so
what that
in some way suggested to me was
sleep evolved with life itself on it
this planet and then it has fought its
way through heroically every step along
the evolutionary pathway
which then leads to the
sort of famous um sleep statement from a
researcher that if sleep doesn't serve
an absolutely vital function or
functions then it's the biggest mistake
the evolutionary process has ever ever
made and we've now realized mother
nature didn't make a spectacular blender
with sleep
you've mentioned the idea of conscious
states
do you think of sleep as a fundamentally
different conscious state than
awake awakenness
and how many conscious states are there
so when you're intuit your understanding
of what the mind can do do you think
awake state sleep state or is there some
kind of continuum
there's a complicated state transition
diagram like how do you think about this
whole space
i think about it as a state space
diagram and i think it's probably more
of a continuum than we have
believed it to be or suggested it to be
so we used to think
absent of anesthesia that there were
really three main main states of
consciousness there was being awake
being in non-rapid eye movement sleep or
non-dream sleep and then being in rapid
eye movement sleep or dream sleep and
those were the three states within which
your brain could
percolate and be conscious i you know
conscious during non-rem sleep is maybe
a stretch to say but i still believe
there is plenty of consciousness there
i don't believe that though anymore
and the reason is because we can have
daydreams
and we are in a very different wakeful
state in those day dreams than we are
when we are as we are now together
present and
extraceptively focused rather than
intraceptively focused
and then we also know that as you are
sort of progressing into those different
stages of sleep during non-rem sleep you
can also still dream depends on your
definition of dreaming but we seem to
have some degree of dreaming in almost
all stages of sleep
we've also then found that when you are
sleep deprived
there even individual brain cells will
fall asleep
despite the animal being
you know behaviorally from best we can
tell awake
individual brain cells and clusters of
brain cells will go into a sleep-like
state and humans do this too when we are
sleep deprived we have what are called
micro sleeps where the eyelid will
partially close
and the brain essentially falls lapses
into a state of sleep but behaviorally
you seem to be awake and the danger here
is road traffic accidents
so
these are the what we call these sort of
micro sleep events at the wheel now if
you're traveling at
65 miles an hour in a two ton vehicle
you know it takes probably around one
second to drift from one lane to the
next and it takes two seconds to go
completely off the road
so if you have one of these micro sleeps
at the wheel you know it could be the
last microsleep that you ever have
but i don't now see it as a set of you
know very binary distinct you know step
function state it's not a one or a zero
i see it more of a as a continuum yeah
so i've for
for uh
five six years at mit
really focused on this
human side of driving question and one
of the big concerns is
the
micro sleeps drowsiness these kinds of
ideas and one of the open questions was
is it possible through computer vision
to detect or any kind of sensors
the nice thing about computer vision is
you don't have to have direct contact to
the person
is it possible to detect
increases in uh drowsiness is it
possible to detect these kind of micro
sleeps or actually just sleep in general
um
among other things like distraction
these are all words that have so many
meanings and so many debates like
like attention is a whole nother one
just because you're looking something
doesn't mean
you're loading in the information just
because you're looking away doesn't mean
your peripheral vision can't pick up the
important information there's so many
complicated vision science things there
um so i i wonder if you could say
something to
uh you know they say the eyes or the
windows to the soul do you think um
the eyes can reveal
something about uh
sleepiness uh through uh through
computer vision through
just looking at the video of the face
and andrew huberman and i your friend
have talked about this so we'd love to
work on this uh together so you should
do it it's a fascinating problem but
drowsiness is a tricky one so there's
what kind of information
there's uh blinking and there's eye
movement
and those are the ones that can be
picked uh up with computer vision do you
think those are signals that could be
used to say something about
where we are in this continuum yeah i do
and i think there are a number of other
features too i think um you know
aperture of i so in other words partial
closures foreclosures
duration of those closures duration of
those partial closures of the eyelid
um i think there may be some information
in the pupil as well
because as we're transitioning between
those states change there are changes in
what's called the automatic nervous
system or technically it's called the
autonomic nervous system part of which
will control your
pupillary size
so i actually think that there is
probably a wealth of information when
you combine that probably with
aspects of steering angle steering
maneuver
and if you can sense the pressure
on the pedals as well
my guess is that there is some
combinatorial feature
that creates a phenotype
of
you are starting to fall asleep and
as the autonomous controls develop
the
it's time for them to kick in some
manufacturers auto manufacturers sort of
have something
beta version maybe an alpha version of
of this already starting to come online
where they have a little camera in the
wheel that i think tries to look at some
features almost everybody doing this and
it's very alpha
so
uh you know the thing that you currently
have some people have that in their car
there's a coffee cup or something that
comes up that you might be sleepy the
the primary signal that they're
comfortable using is the steering wheel
reversals so so basically using your
interaction with the steering wheel and
how much you're interacting with it as a
sign of sleepiness so if you have to
constantly correct the car yeah that's a
sign of like you starting to drift into
micro sleep i think that's a very very
crude signal it's probably a powerful
one there's a whole other component to
this which is
it seems like it's so driver and
subject-dependent
the
how our behavior changes as we
get sleepy and drowsy seems to be
different in complicated fascinating
ways where you can't just use one signal
it's kind of like what you're saying
there has to be a lot of different
signals that you should then be able to
combine the hope is there's uh the
searches for like universal signals that
are pretty damn good for like ninety
percent of people
but i don't think we need to take
necessarily quite that approach i think
what we could do in some clever fashion
is
using the individual so what you and i
are perhaps suggesting here is that
there is
an array of features that we know
provide information that is sensitive to
whether or not you're falling asleep at
the wheel
some of those let's say that there are
ten of them you know for me seven of
them are the cardinal features for you
however you know six of them and they're
not all the same sort of overlapping are
those for you
i think what we need is algorithms that
can firstly understand when you are well
slept so let's say that people have
sleep trackers at night and then your
car integrates that information that'd
be amazing understands when you are well
slept yeah and then you've got the data
of the individual behavior unique to
that individual snowflake like when they
are well slept this is the signature of
well-rested driving
then you can look at deviations from
that and patent match it with the sleep
history of that individual and then i
don't need to find
the sort of you know the
one-size-fits-all approach for 99 of the
people i can create a very bespoke
tailor-like set of features the savile
row suit of sleepiness features you know
that would be my if you want to ask me
about moonshots and crazy ideas that's
where i go but to start with i think
your approaches is a great one let's
find something that covers 99 of the
people because the worrying thing about
microsleeps of course unlike you know
drugs or alcohol which you know
certainly is a terrible thing to be
behind the wheel
with those often you
you react too late
and that's the reason you get into an
accident
when you fall asleep behind the wheel
you don't react at all
the you know at that point there is a
two-ton missile driving down the street
and no one's in control that's why those
accidents can often be more dangerous
yeah and
the fascinating thing is in the case of
semi-autonomous vehicles like tesla
autopilot this is where
i've had disagreements with mr elon musk
is uh
and uh the human factors community
which is this community that one of the
big things they study
is uh human supervision over automation
so you have like pilots
you know supervising an airplane that's
mostly flying autonomously the question
is
when we're actually doing the driving
how do micro sleeps or general how does
drowsiness progress and how does it
affect our driving that question becomes
more fascinating more complicated
when your task is not driving but
supervising the driving so your task is
to take over when stuff goes wrong and
that
is complicated but
the basic conclusions from many decades
is that humans are really crappy at
supervising
because they get
they get drowsy and lose vigilance much
much faster
the really surprising thing with tesla
autopilot it was surprising to me it's
surprising to uh the human factors
community and in fact they still argue
with me about it is uh it seems that
humans
in tesla's with autopilot
and other similar systems are not
becoming less vigilant
at least
the with with the studies we've done so
there's something about the urgency of
driving
i can't i'm not sure the why but there's
something about the risk i think the
fact that you might die
is still keeping people
awake the question is as tesla autopilot
or similar systems get better and better
and better
how does that affect increasing
drowsiness and that's when you need to
have that's what the big disagreement
was you need to have driver sensing
meaning driver facing camera
that
tracks some kind of information about
the face that can tell you
uh drowsiness so you can tell the car if
you're drowsy so that the car can be
like you should be
probably driving or pull to the side
right or i need to do some of the heavy
lifting here yeah um so there needs to
be that dance of inter interaction
of a human and machine
but currently it's mostly uh steering
wheel based so
you know this this idea that your hands
should be on the on the steering wheel
that's
uh a sign that you're paying attention
is um isn't outdated and a very crude
metric i agree
yeah i think there are far more
sophisticated ways that we can solve
that problem
uh if we invest
big philosophical question
before we get into fun details um
on the topic of conscious states
how fundamental do you think is
consciousness to the human mind
i ask this from almost like a robotics
perspective so in your study of sleep
do you think
the the hard question of consciousness
that it feels like something
to be us
is that like a nice little feature like
a like a like a quark of our mind or is
it somehow fundamental because sleep
feels like we take we take a step out of
that consciousness a little bit
so from all your study of sleep
do you think consciousness is like
deeply part of who we are or is it just
a nice trick
i think it's a deeply embedded feature
that i can imagine has
a whole panoply of biological benefits
but to your point about sleep what is
interesting if you do a lot of dream
research and we've done some
it's very very rare
at all in fact for you to end up
becoming someone other than who you are
in your dreams now you can have
third-person perspective dreams where
you can see yourself in the dream as if
you're sort of
you know you've risen above your
your physical being
but for the most part it's very rare
that we lose our sense of conscious self
and maybe i'm sort of doing a sleight of
hand because it's really what i'm saying
it's very rare that we lose our sense of
who we are in dreams we never do now
that's not to suggest that dreams aren't
utterly
bizarre and
i mean you know when you slept last
night which i know um may have been
perhaps a little less than than me but
when you went into dreaming you know you
became flagrantly psychotic
and there are five essentially good
reasons firstly you started to see
things which were not there so you were
hallucinating
second you believe things that couldn't
possibly be true so you were delusional
third you became confused about time and
place and person so you're suffering
from what we would call disorientation
fourth you have wildly fluctuating
emotions something that um psychiatrists
will call being affectively labile
and then how wonderful you woke up this
morning and you forgot most if not all
of that dream experience so you're
suffering from amnesia if you had to
experience any one of those five things
while you're awake you would probably be
seeking psychological help
but what so i placed that as a backdrop
against your astute question because
despite all of that
psychosis
there is still a present
self
nested at the heart of it
meaning that i think it's very difficult
for us
to
abandon our conscious sense of self and
if it's that hard you know the old adage
in some ways that you can't outrun your
shadow but here it's more of a
philosophical question which is about
the conscious mind and what the state of
consciousness actually means in a human
being
so i think that that to me you can
you become
so dislocated from so many other
rational ways of waking consciousness
but one thing that won't go away that
won't get
perturbed
or sort of
you know
manicled is this your sense of conscious
self yeah that's a strong sign that
consciousness is fundamental to the
human mind
um or we're just creatures of habit
we've gotten used to having
consciousness maybe it just takes a lot
of uh
either chemical substances or a lot of
like
mental work to escape that i mean it's
like trying to launch
a rocket
you know the energy that has to be put
in to create escape velocity
from the gravitational pull of this
thing called planet earth is immense
yeah well the same thing is true
for
for us to abandon our sense of conscious
self the amount of biological the amount
of substances the amount of wacky stuff
that you have to do to truly get escaped
velocity from your conscious self
what does that tell us about then the
fundamental
state of our conscious self
yeah it also probably says that that
it's quite useful to have consciousness
for uh for survival and for just
operation in this world and perhaps for
intelligence i'm one of the on the ai
side people that think
that uh
intelligence requires consciousness so
like high levels of general intelligence
requires consciousness
most people in the ai field think like
consciousness and intelligence are
fundamentally different you can build a
computer that's super intelligent it
doesn't have to be conscious
i think that
if you define super intelligence by
being good at chess yes but if you
define super intelligence as being able
to operate in this living world of
humans
and be able to perform all kinds of
different tasks consciousness
it seems to be somehow fundamental
to uh like to to to richly integrate
yourself into the human experience into
society it feels like you have to be a
conscious being
but then we don't even know what
consciousness is and we certainly don't
know how to engineer it in our machines
i love the fact that there are still
questions that are so embryonic
because you know i suspect it's the same
with you
answers to me are simply ways to get to
more questions you know it's questions
where
you know questions turn me on answers
less so
and i love the fact that we are still
embryonic in our sense of arguing about
even what the definition of
consciousness is but i also find it
fascinating i i think it's thoroughly
delightful to absorb yourself in the
thought
think about the brain and we can move
back across the complexity of phylogeny
from you know humans to mammals to sort
of birds to reptiles amphibians fish and
you can
bacteria whatever you want and you can
go through this and say okay where is
the hard line of you know what we would
define as consciousness and
and i'm sure it's got something to do
with the complexity of the neural system
of that i'm fairly certain
but
to me it's always been fascinating
so what is it then you know is it that i
just keep adding neurons to a petri dish
and i just keep adding them and adding
them and adding them at some point when
i hit a critical mass of interconnected
neurons that is the mass of the you know
the interconnected human brain then
bingo
all of a sudden it kicks into gear and
we have consciousness like a phase shift
phase transition of some kind correct
yeah but there is something about the
complexity of the nervous system that i
think is fundamental to consciousness
and the reason i bring that up is
because
when we're trying to then think about
creating it in an artificial way does
that inform us as to the complexity that
we should be looking at in terms of
development
i also think that it's a missed
opportunity in the
sort of digital space for us to try to
recreate human consciousness
we've already got human consciousness
what if we were to think about
creating some other form of why do we
have to think that
the ultimate in the creation of you know
an artificial intelligence is the
replication
you know
of a human
state of consciousness can we not think
outside of our own
consciousness and believe that there is
something even more incredible or
more complementary more orthogonal
[Music]
so i'm sometimes
perplexed that people are trying to
mimic human consciousness rather than
think about creating
something that's different yeah i think
of human consciousness or consciousness
in general is this magic
um
superpower that allows us to deeply
experience the world and just as you're
saying i don't think that superpower has
to take the exact flavor as humans have
that's my love for robots
i would love to
add the ability to robots that can
experience the world and other humans
uh deeply i'm humbled by the fact that
that idea does not necessarily need to
look anything like
how humans experience the world
but there's a dance of um
human to robot connection the same way
human to dog a human to cat connection
that there's a there's a there's a magic
there to that interaction and i'm not
sure how to create that magic but it's a
worthy effort i also love just exactly
as you said
on the question of consciousness or
engineering consciousness
the fun thing about this problem
is it seems obvious to me that a hundred
years from now
no matter what we do today
uh people if we're still here
will
laugh
at how silly our notions were so like
it's almost impossible for me to imagine
that we will truly solve this problem
fully
in my lifetime
and and more than that everything we'll
do
will be silly 100 years from now but
it's still a war that makes it fun to me
because it's like you have the full
freedom to not even be right
just to try just to try as freedom and
uh
and i that's how i see that t-shirt
please
i love that so i and you know the human
robot interaction is fascinating because
it's like it's like watching dancing
i've been uh
dancing tango recently and just it's
like there is no goal the goal is to
create something magical
and uh
whether consciousness or emotion or
elegance of movement all of those things
uh aid in the creation of the magic and
it's a free it's an art form to explore
how how to make that um
how to create that in a way that's
compelling yeah i love that the line in
sense of a woman with al pacino where
he's speaking about the tango and he
said really it's just freedom that
if you get tangled up you just keep
tangoing on
i still to this day
i think uh well first the second time i
talked to joe rogan on his podcast
i said we got into this heated argument
about whether a
sensible woman is a better movie than
john wick
because it's one of my favorite movies
for many reasons one is for sensible
women some scent of a woman uh partially
know that by the way it's just you just
yeah i don't know if you would actually
know of awesome awesome yeah yeah i said
i love the tango scene i love al
pacino's performance
it's a wonderful movie
then joe joe was saying john wick is
better so we to this day argue about
this i think it depends in on what
conscious state you're in yes that you
would be ready and receptive to but um
sense of woman i think it has one of the
best monologues at the end of the movie
that has ever been written or at least
performed
when al pacino
defends the
the younger
yeah i
uh
i often think about that there's been
times in my life
i don't know about you
where i wish i had an al pacino in my
life
where
um
integrity is really important in this
life it is and sometimes you find
yourself in places where
there's pressure to sacrifice that
integrity and you want uh what is it
lieutenant colonel or whatever he was
coming
yeah
come in uh on your side and scream at
everyone and say what the hell are we
doing here
being you know unfortunately
british and sort of having that slightly
um
awkward sort of huge grand gene it's
it's very very
at the opposite end of the spectrum of
the remarkable feat of uh al pacino at
the end of that scene but um and yeah
integrity is um it's a
challenging
thing and i value it much and i think
um
it can take 20 years to build a
reputation in two minutes to lose it and
there is nothing more that i value than
but integrity and
you know if i'm ever wrong about
anything i truly don't want to be
wrong for any longer than i have to be
um
you know that's what being in some ways
a scientist is you're
you're just driven by truth and the
irony relative to something like
mathematics is that in science you never
find truth what all you do in science is
you discount the things that are likely
to be untrue
leaving only the possibility of what
could be true yeah but in math
you know when you create
you know a proof it's a proof for
you know
from that point forward there is truth
in mathematics and there's i think
there's a beauty in that
but i kind of like the messiness of of
science because again
to me it's less about the truth of the
answer and it is more about the pursuit
of questions but their integrity becomes
more and more important and it becomes
more difficult there's a lot of
pressures just like in the rest of the
world but
there's a lot of pressures on a
scientist one is like funding sources
yeah i've noticed this that um you know
money affects everyone's mind i think
i've been always somebody that
i believe money can't you can't buy
my opinion uh i don't care how much
money billions or trillions
the
but that pressure is there and you have
to be very cognizant of it and make sure
that
your opinion is not defined by the
funding sources
and then the other is just your own
success
of uh you know for a couple of decades
publishing an idea
um
and then realizing at some point that
that idea was wrong all along right and
that that's a tough thing for people to
do but that's also integrity is to walk
away is to say that you were wrong
um
that doesn't have to be in some big
dramatic way it could be in a bunch of
tiny ways along the way right
like uh reconfigure your intuition about
a particular
uh problem
that's and all of that is integrity when
everybody in the room
uh you know believes a certain thing
everybody in the community believes a
certain thing
to uh to be able to still be open-minded
in the face of that
yeah and i think it comes down in some
ways to the issue of ego that you bond
your you know correctness or your
rightness your scientific theory with
your sense of
ego
you know i've never found it that
difficult to let go of
theories in the face of counter evidence
in part because i have such low
self-esteem well i i kind of like that i
always like that combination i have the
same i'm like very self-critical
imposter syndrome all those things
uh putting yourself below the podium but
at the same time having the ego that
drives the ambition to work your ass off
like some kind of weird drive
maybe
like to drive to be better like thinking
yourself is not that great and always
driving to be better and at the same
time because that's that can be
paralyzing and exhausting
and so on at the same time just being
grateful to be alive but in the sciences
in the actual effort
never be satisfied never think of
yourself highly that seems to be a nice
combination i very much hope that that
is part of who i am and i
remain very quietly motivated and driven
and i like you
love the idea of perfection and i know i
will never achieve it but i will never
stop trying to so
similar to you which sounds weird
because there's all these videos of uh
of me on the internet
so i think i think i just naturally lean
into the things i'm afraid of and i'm
uncomfortable doing yeah like i'm very
afraid of talking to people and you know
just even
before talking to you today just a lot
of anxiety anxiety and all those kinds
of things about talking to me yeah yeah
oh
nervousness
uh fear in some cases uh self-doubt and
all those kinds of things
but i do it anyway so the reason i bring
that up is um
you've uh launched a podcast
i have
allow me to say i think you're a great
science communicator so this
challenge of
being
afraid or
cautious of being in the public eye and
yet
having a longing to communicate some of
the things you're excited about
in the space of sleep and beyond
what's your vision with this project
i think firstly to your to that question
like you i am always more afraid of not
trying than trying
yeah
that to me frightens me more
but with the podcast i think
really i have two very simple goals
i want to try and democratize the
science of sleep
and in doing so my goal would be to try
and reunite humanity with the sleep that
it is so desperately bereft of
and if i can do that through a number of
different means
um
the podcast is a little bit different
than this format it's are going to be
short form monologues
from yours truly uh that will last
usually less than just 10 minutes and i
see it as simply a little slice of sleep
goodness that can accompany your waking
day it's hard to know what is the right
way to do science communication like uh
your friend mine andrew huberman
is does he he's an incredible human
being okay so he does like two hours
of i wonder how many takes he does i
don't know but it looks like he doesn't
do anything
he's that magnificent of a human being
when i talk to him in like in person
he always generates intelligent words
well cited non-stop for hours so i don't
he's a gatling gun of information and
it's pristine and passion and all those
kinds of things so that's an interesting
medium i
i wouldn't have um
it's funny because i wouldn't have done
it the way he's doing it i wouldn't
advise him to do it the way he's doing
it because i thought there's no way you
could do what you're doing
because it's a lot of work uh but he is
like
doing an incredible job of it i just
think
it's the same with like dan carlin in
hardcore history i thought
i thought that the way andrew's doing it
would crush him the way
he crushes dan carlin so dan has so much
pressure on him to do a good job that he
ends up publishing like two episodes a
year
so that pressure can be paralyzing the
pressure of like
putting out like
strong scientific statements that that
can be overwhelming now andrew seems to
be just plowing through anyway if
there's mistakes he'll he'll say there's
corrections and so on yeah i just i
wonder i actually haven't talked to him
too much about it like psychologically
how difficult is it
to put yourself out there for an hour
two a week
of just non-stop dropping knowledge
any one sentence of which could be
totally wrong it could be a mistake and
there will be yeah mistakes you know and
i you know in the first edition of my
book there were errors that you know we
corrected in the second edition too
but
there will be probabilistically you know
if you've got you know 10 facts per page
of a book and you've got
350 pages
odds are it's probably not going to be
utter perfection out the gate and it
will be the same way for andrew too
but having the
the reverence of
um
a humble mind
and simply accepting the things that are
wrong and correcting them and doing the
right thing i know that that's his
mentality
i
do want to say that i'm just kind of
honored to be
it's like it's a cool group of like
scientific people that uh i'm fortunate
enough to not be interacting with this
is you and andrew and um david sinclair
has been thinking about throwing his hat
in the ring oh i hope so david is
another one of those very special people
in the world so it's cool because
podcasts are
it's cool it's a it's such a powerful
medium of communication it's much freer
than more constrained like publications
and so on or it's much more accessible
and inspiring than like i don't know
conference presentations or lectures and
it's it's a really exciting medium to me
and it's cool that there's this like
group of people that uh
are becoming friends and putting stuff
out there and supporting each other so
it's fun to also watch
how that's going to evolve in your case
because it wonder it'd be too much
is the answer to that like
well i mean some of it is persistence
through the challenges that we've been
talking about which is like i think i've
got a lot to learn yeah but i will
persist
look can i ask you some detailed stuff
you mentioned that goodness go anywhere
you wish with sleep uh so
i'm a big fan of coffee and caffeine
and i've been
especially the last few days consuming a
very large amount
and i'm cognizant of the fact that
my body is affected by caffeine
different than
the anecdotal information that other
people tell me
i seem to be not at all affected by it
it's almost
um
it feels like more like a ritual then it
is a chemical boost to my performance
like i can drink several cups of coffee
right before bed and just knock out
anyway
i'm not sure if it's a biological
chemical or it has to do with just the
fact that i'm just consuming huge
amounts of caffeine all that to say
uh
what do you think is the relationship
between coffee and sleep caffeine and
sleep if there's an interesting
distinction there there is a distinction
so i think the first thing to say which
is going to sound strange coming from me
is drink coffee
um the health benefits associated with
drinking coffee are
really quite well established now
um
but i think that the counterpoint to
that well firstly the dose and the
timing make the poison and i'll perhaps
come back to that in just a second
but for
coffee
it's actually not the caffeine
so
you know a lot of people have asked me
about this rightful paradox between the
fact that sleep provides all of these
incredible health benefits
and then coffee which can have a
deleterious
impact on your sleep has
a whole collection of health benefits
many of them venn diagram overlapping
with those that sleep provides how on
earth can you reconcile those two
and the answer is that
well the answer is very simple it's
called
antioxidants
but it turns out that for most people in
western civilization because of diet not
being quite what it should be
the major source through which they
obtain antioxidants is the coffee bean
so the the humble coffee bean has now
been asked to carry the astronomical
weight
of serving up the large majority of
people's antioxidant needs
and
you can see this if for example you look
at the health benefits of decaffeinated
coffee it has a whole constellation of
really great health benefits too so it's
not like caffeine and that's why i liked
what you said this sort of separation of
church and state between coffee and
caffeine it's not the caffeine it's the
coffee bean itself that provides those
health benefits but
coming back to how it impacts sleep it
impacts sleep in probably at least three
different ways
the first is that for most people
caffeine can make it obviously a little
harder to fall asleep
caffeine can make it harder to stay
asleep
but let's say that you are one of those
individuals and i think you are
and you can say look i can have three or
four espressos with dinner and i fall
asleep just fine and i stay asleep
soundly across the light so there's no
problem
the downside there is that even if that
is true the amount of deep sleep that
you get will not be as deep and so you
will actually lose somewhere between 10
to 30 percent of your deep sleep if you
drink caffeine in the evening
so to give you some context to to drop
your deep sleep by let's say 20 i'd
probably have to age you by 15 years or
you could do it every night with a cup
of coffee
i think the fourth component that is
perhaps less well understood about
coffee is its timing and that's why i
was saying the timing and the dose make
the poison the dose by the way once you
get past about three cups of coffee a
day the health benefits actually start
to turn down in the opposite direction
so there is a u-shape function it's sort
of you know the goldilocks syndrome not
too little not too much just the right
amount
the second component is the timing
though caffeine has a half-life of about
five to six hours
meaning that after five to six hours
fifty percent of that on average for the
average adult is still in the system
which means that it has a quarter life
of 10 to 12 hours so in other words if
you have a coffee at noon a quarter of
that caffeine is still circulating in
your brain at midnight
so having a cup of coffee at noon one
could argue is the equivalent of tucking
yourself into bed at midnight and before
you turn the light out you swig a
quarter of a cup of coffee but that
doesn't still answer your question as to
why are you so immune so i'm someone who
is actually unfortunately very sensitive
to caffeine and if i have you know even
two cups of coffee in the morning
i i don't sleep as well that night and i
find it miserable because i love the
smell of coffee i love the routine i
love the ritual i think i would love to
be invested in it it's just terrible for
my sleep so i switched to decaf
there is a difference from one
individual to the next and it's
controlled by a set of liver enzymes
called
cytochrome p450 enzymes and there is a
particular gene
that if you have a different sort of
version of this gene it's called cyp
1 a 2
that gene will determine the speed of
the clearance of caffeine from your
system some people will have a version
of that gene that is very effective and
efficient at clearing that caffeine and
so their half-life could be as short as
two hours rather than five to six hours
other people hands up matt walker um
have a version of that gene that is not
very effective at clearing out the uh
the caffeine and therefore the half-life
sort of sensitivity could be somewhere
between you know eight to nine hours
so we understand that there are
individual differences but overall i
guess the
top line here is
drink coffee um and understand that it's
not the caffeine it's the coffee that's
the benefit and the dose makes the
poison is there some aspect to it that's
it's like a muscle
in terms of the
all the combination of letters and
numbers that you just said is there some
aspect that if um
i can improve
the quarter life the half-life
can decrease that number if i just
practice
like i drink a lot of coffee so like
habit
alters how your body is able to get rid
of the caffeine not how the body is able
to get rid of the caffeine but it does
alter how sensitive
the body is to the caffeine and it's not
at the level of the enzyme degrading the
caffeine it's at the level of the
receptors that caffeine will act upon
now it turns out that those are called
adenosine receptors and maybe we can
speak about what adenosine is and sleep
pressure and all of that good stuff but
as you start to drink more and more
coffee
the body tries to fight back and it
happens with many different drugs by the
way and it's called tolerance
and so one of the ways that your body
becomes tolerant to a drug is that the
receptors that the drug is binding to
these sort of welcome sites these sort
of you know picture myths as it were
that receive the drug
those start to get
taken away from the surface of the cell
and it's what we call receptor
internalization
so the cell starts to think gee where's
you know this there's a lot of
stimulation going on this is too much so
i'm just going to
when normally i would you know coat my
cell with let's just say five of these
receptors for argument's sake
things are going a little bit too
ballistic right now i'm going to take
away at least two of those receptors and
downscale it to just having three of
those
and now you need two cups of coffee to
get the same effect that one cup of
coffee got you before
and that's why then when you go
cold turkey on coffee all of a sudden
the system has equilibriated itself to
expecting x amount of stimulation and
now all of that stimulation is gone so
it's now got too few receptors and you
have a caffeine withdrawal syndrome
and that's why for example with you know
drugs of abuse things like heroin when
people go into abstinence
you know as they're sort of moving into
their addiction
they will build up a progressive
tolerance to that drug so they need to
take more of it to get the same high but
then if they go cold turkey
for some period of time the system goes
back to being more sensitive again it
starts to repopulate the surface of the
cell with these receptors but now when
they reuse and they fall off the wagon
if they go back to the same dose that
they were using before
you know 10 weeks ago or three months
ago
that dose
can kill them they can have an overdose
even though they were using the same
amount at those two different times the
difference is that it's not the dose of
the drug it's the sensitivity of the
system and that's the same thing that we
see with caffeine in terms of training
the muscle as it were is the system
becomes less sensitive can calibrate
is there a time
the number of hours before bed
that's a safe bet
to most people to recommend
you shouldn't drink caffeine this many
hours
like is there an average half-life that
you should be aiming at
yeah or is this advice kind of
impossible because there's so much
variability there is a huge variability
and i think everyone themselves you know
to a degree knows it although i'll put a
caveat on that too because it's slightly
dangerous point
so the recommendation for the average
adult and who where is the average adult
in society there is no such thing but
for the average adult
it would be probably cutting yourself
off maybe 10 hours you know before so
assuming a normative bedtime in society
i would say try to stop drinking
caffeine you know
before 2 pm and
just keep an eye out you know and if
you're struggling with sleep dial down
the caffeine and see if it makes a
difference
can i ask you about sleep
and
learning
so
how does sleep affect learning
sleep
before learning sleep after learning
which are both fascinating kind of
dynamics
of the mind's interaction with this
extra conscious state
yeah sleep is
profoundly
and very intimately related to your
memory systems and your informational
systems
the first as you just mentioned is that
sleep before learning will essentially
prepare your brain
almost like a dry sponge ready to sort
of
initially soak up new information in
other words you need sleep before
learning to effectively imprint
information into the brain to lay down
fresh memory traces and without sleep
the memory circuits of the brain and we
know we've studied these memory circuits
it will
you know essentially become waterlogged
as it were for the sponge analogy and
you can't absorb
the information as effectively
so you need sleep before learning but
you also need sleep unfortunately after
learning too
to then take those freshly minted
memories and effectively hit the save
button on them but it's nowhere near as
quick as a digital system it takes hours
because it's a physical biological
change that happens at the level of
brain cells but sleep after learning
will cement and solidify that new memory
into the neural architecture of the
brain therefore making it less likely to
be forgotten
so
you know i often think of sleep in that
way as
it's almost sort of future proofing
information
in in what way well it means that it
gives it a higher degree of assurance
to be remembered in the future rather
than go through
the sort of degradation that we think of
as forgetting
so
the brain has
in some ways by default you know
there is forget and actually i would
love to
i was going to say sleep is relevant for
memory in three different ways but i'm
going to amend that and say this four
different ways
which is learning
maintaining memorizing
abstraction assimilation
association and then forgetting which
the last one sounds oxymoronic based on
the form of three but i'll see if i can
explain
so sleep after learning then sort of you
know
sets the that information like amber
in you know in solidification
the third benefit however is that sleep
we've learned more recently is much more
intelligent than we ever gave it credit
for
sleep doesn't simply just take
individual memories
and strengthen them
sleep will then
intelligently integrate and cross link
and associate that information together
and it's almost like informational
alchemy
so that you wake up the next morning
with a revised mind wide web of
associations
and that's probably the reason that you
know you've never been told to stay
awake on a
problem you know
and
in every language that i've been quiet
about that phrase or very something very
similar seems to exist which means to me
that
this creative associative benefit of
sleep transcends cultural boundaries it
is a common experience across humanity
now i should note that i think the
french translation of that is much
closer to you um i think you sleep with
a problem whereas the british you sleep
on a problem the french you sleep with a
problem i think it says so much about
the romantic difference between the
british and the french but let's let's
not go there um that's brilliant so such
a subtle but such a fundamental
difference yeah
yeah goodness me sleep with the problem
yes exactly right
um
so
and we can sort of double click on any
one of these and go in into detail but
the fourth i became really enchanted by
about
eight years ago in our research which
was this idea of forgetting
and i started to
think that forgetting may be the price
that we pay for remembering
and in that sense
there is an enormous
benefit
to letting
go you may be thinking that sounds
ridiculous i don't want to forget in
fact my biggest problem is i keep
forgetting things
but
the brain
it has a fight well we believe has a
finite storage capacity we can't prove
it yet but my suspicion is that that's
probably true it doesn't have an
infinite storage capacity it has
constraints
if that's the case we can't simply go
through life being you know
constantly informational aggregators
unless you know we are programmed to say
we've got a hard drive space of about 85
to 90 years and we're good and we can do
that maybe that's true i don't think
that's true i think forgetting is an
incredibly good and useful thing so for
example
you know
it's not beneficial from an evolutionary
perspective for me to remember where i
parked my car three years ago
so it's important that i can remember
today's parking spot but i don't want to
have the junk
kind of dna from a memory perspective of
you know where my i parked my car you
know two years ago um
now i actually have a in some ways a
problem with forgetting i'm and again
i'm not trying to sort of be laudatory
but
you know i i tend not to forget too many
things and i don't think that that's a
good thing
and um the there's a wonderful
neurologist laurea who wrote a book
called the mind of the mnemonicist and
it was a brilliant book
both because it was written exquisitely
but he was studying
these sort of memory savants
who basically could remember everything
that he gave them
and he tried to find
a [ __ ] in their armor
and the first half of the book is
essentially about him
seeing how far he can push them before
they fail
and he never found that place
he could never find a place where they
stopped
remembering and then in his brilliance
he turned the question on its head he
said not what is the benefit of
constantly remembering
but instead what is the detriment
to never forgetting
and when you start to realize his
descriptions of those individuals it's
probably a life that you would not want
but it's fascinating both from a human
perspective but also ai perspective
there's a
there's a big challenge in the machine
learning community of how to build
systems that are able to remember for
prolonged periods of time
lifelong continuous learning so where
you build up
information over time so memory is one
of the biggest open problems in uh
in ai and machine learning
but at the same time the right way to
formulate memory
is actually forgetting
because
you have to be exceptionally selective
at which kind of stuff you remember
and that's where the step of a
simulation integration that you're
referring to is really important i mean
we forget most of the things and and the
question is exactly the cost of
forgetting
at the very edge
of stuff that could be important or
could not be
how do we remember not those things like
for example
i've uh you know doing a podcast i've
become
cognizant of one feature of my
forgetting that's been problematic
which is i forget names and titles of
books and so on so when i read
i remember ideas
i remember quotes
i remember statements and like that's
the space in which i'm thinking
but when you communicate to others
you have to say this person in this book
said that
it's the same thing with uh with like
andrew huberman is masterful with this
this is important academia remembering
the authors of a paper and the title of
the paper
as part of remembering the idea
and i've been feeling the cost of not
not being able to naturally remember
those things and so that that's
something i need to sort of work on but
that's an exact with faces
yes very good at faces but not good with
names so i am exactly like
you and there is you know an
understanding of that in the brain too
we understand that there is partitioning
of those in terms of the territory of
the brain that takes care of faces and
facts and places and they can be
separate so i will never forget
a face but you know and as i said i
usually forget very little but for some
reason names are
a struggle i think in some ways because
i'm probably just a slightly anxious
person so when you first meet someone
which is usually the time when a name is
introduced you know you were saying you
were sort of anxious maybe about sort of
sitting down with me um but
i find that a little bit
you know activating and so
it's not as though there's anything
wrong with my memory it's just
the emotional state i'm in when i'm
first meeting someone yeah you know it's
a little bit perturbing but i will never
forget the face but um i completely
relate to that because i almost don't
hear uh people's names when they tell me
because i'm so anxious yeah yeah
but i i think there's certain quirks of
social interaction
that uh show that you care about the
person that you remember that person
that they mattered to you they had an
impact on you and one of the ways to
show that is you remember their name
and but that's a quirk to me because
there's
a lot of people i meet have a deep
impact on me
but
they i can't communicate that unless i
know their name unless i know some of
the
um
details that that we humans seem to use
to communicate that will remember each
other what i i remember well
is the feeling we shared
is the experience we shared
what i don't remember well is the
detailed labels of of those experiences
and i need to certainly work on that i i
don't know i think it's you know just
allowing yourself to be innate and who
you are is also a beautiful thing too
i'm not suggesting it's not important to
try and better oneself and
but i also sometimes worry about the
misery that that puts us in but
like you i will
i do struggle with him but
i know for the first time when we met in
the lobby
um i know exactly
what you look like i know that you were
wearing headphones i know the shape and
the size of those headphones you didn't
have your black jacket on i know exactly
what the weave of your shirt looked like
and you know what your shoes look like
and i knew exactly the height of your
the end of your pants from the top of
your shoes yeah and so those things i
don't forget you know and i can that's
fascinating remember when people i met
people you know two years ago and i'll
say oh yes we met there and um i
remember you had those fantastic you
know boots on i thought they were pretty
great pair of boots you know and they're
like how do you i didn't even remember
what i was wearing that day yeah it's
fascinating yeah i'm the exact the same
way but you can't
until we have neurolink or something
like that we can't communicate that you
remember all those things i know that's
what i wanted so you have to be able to
use uh tricks of human communication for
that but so that i mean that's the it
ultimately is a trick of like which to
remember which to forget right and the
forgetting is so it's so fascinating to
say this i mean it seems to be
deeply connected to that assimilation
process so forgetting you try to fit
all the new stuff into
this big web of the old stuff
and the things that don't fit you throw
out
i think the assimilation the way i've
been thinking about it with sleep and
it's particularly sort of dream sleep
that we think can help with this
assimilation
is that
during wake we have one version of
associative processing what i mean by
that is we see the most obvious
connections
so i think of wakefulness
as a google search gone right
whereas i see dream sleep as doing
something very different i think dream
sleep is a little bit like group therapy
for memories
that everyone gets a name badge and
sleep gathers in all of the individual
pieces of the day and it sort of starts
to get you to forces you in fact to
speak to the people not at the front of
the room that you think you've got the
most obvious connection with but to
speak with the people all the way at the
back of the room that at first you think
i've got no obvious connection with them
at all but once you get chatting with
them
you learn that you do have a very
distant non-obvious connection but it's
still a connection not the same
and it's almost as though you're doing a
google search where you know i input you
know lex friedman and
it doesn't take me to the first page of
your home site page 20. it takes me to
page 20 which is about some like field
hockey game in utah yeah exactly it
turns out that there actually is a link
if i look at it it's a distant
non-obvious one
and to me i find that exciting because
when you fuse things together that
shouldn't normally go together but when
they do they cause marked advances in
evolutionary fitness it sounds like the
biological basis of creativity
and that's exactly what i think dream
sleep and the algorithm of dream sleep
is designed to do you know it's not a
boolean like system where you have
you know the sort of assumptions of true
and false you know maybe it's more fuzzy
logic system and i think rem sleep is a
perfect environment within which we do
you know it's almost like memory pinball
you know you get the information that
you've learned during the day and then
you pull the lever back and you shoot it
up into the attic of your brain
you know this cortex filled with all of
your past historical knowledge and you
start to bounce it around and see where
one of those things lights up and you
build a new connection there and you
build another one there too you're
developing schemas
and so in that way i think you could
argue
you know we dream therefore we are
yeah so in terms of
this line between learning and thinking
through a new thing
that seems to be deeply connected
there's this
legendary engineer named jim keller who
keeps yelling at me about this he says
it's very effective
he likes to
for difficult problems
before bed think about that difficult
problem we're not talking about like
drama at work or all that kind of stuff
no like a scientific for him engineering
problem
he likes to like intensely think about
it
and to prime his mind yes before sleep
and then go to sleep and then uh he
finds that uh
the next day he's he's able to think
much clearer and there's new ideas that
come but also just i guess it's more
well integrated
and sometimes during the process of
like he's able to like wake up
and
like
see new insights that's right if he's
deeply sort of aggressively thinking
through a problem
there's many scientific you know
demonstrations of this you know the
mendeleev with a periodic table of
elements you know he was trying for
months to understand i mean talk about
an
ecumenical problem of epic proportions
here's your question today
you have to understand how all of the
known elements in the universe fit
together in a logical way good luck take
it was non-trivial at the time and he
would try and try he was so obsessed
with it he created playing cards with
all of the different elements on and
then he would go on these long train
journeys around europe and he would just
sort of deal these cards in front of
them and he would shuffle them
shuffling and shuffling and he would
just try to see if he could find what
the answer was and then so the story
goes you know he fell asleep and he had
a dream and in that dream you know all
of these elements started to dance and
play around and they snapped into a
logical grid you know atomic weights etc
etc
and it wasn't his waking brain
that
solved the problem it was his sleeping
brain that solved the impenetrable
problem that his waking brain could not
and there's been count you know even in
the arts and in music
some wonderful dreams you know
frankenstein mary shelley's epic gothic
novel came to her in a dream at lord
byron's home
and then we've got
you know
paul mccartney
yesterday the song came to him in a
dream he was uh filming um
gosh what was the movie um i don't
recall it i should be shocked because
i'm from liverpool myself
um and
but he was on wimpole street in london
um and filming and they he came up with
that song the melody um in his sleep not
to be outdone by the beatles and by the
way let it be um also came from a dream
that mccartney had people usually give
it you know religious overtones you know
mother mary comes to me speaking words
of wisdom let it be
if you've ever asked who mother mary is
it's not the you know the biblical
content it's his
his mother it's it's it's mary mccartney
yeah and she came to him in a dream and
gifted him the song
but the best story i've heard is um not
to be outdone by the beatles the stones
um keith richards uh who i think once
was suggested that
who was it was a comedian who was saying
that
in an interview with rolling stone keith
richards suggested or inferred that
young kids should not do drugs
and they said well look
young kids can't do drugs because you've
done all of that
but keith richards described
he would always go to bed with his um
guitar
and a tape recorder
um and then probably who would have a
whole
set of other things in the bed with him
and who knows how many other people but
anyway uh and then he said in his
autobiography and i'm paraphrasing here
but
one morning i woke up and i realized
that the tape had recorded all the way
to the end so i rewound the tape
and i hit play and there in some kind of
ghostly form were the opening chords to
satisfaction the most famous successful
rolling stone song of all of all time
yeah
followed by then 43 minutes of snoring
that riff came to him one of the most
famous riffs in all of rock and roll
came to him by way of a dream inspired
insight so i think you know
there is
too many of those anecdotes and we've
now got the site you know i don't rely
on anecdotes a science we've now done
the studies in the laboratory and we can
reliably demonstrate that sleep inspires
creativity inspires problem-solving
capacity well the interesting thing is
is it possible to some of the ideas that
you talk about to turn them into a
protocol that could be practiced
rigorously so what jim keller
espouses is
saying not just the fact that sleep
helps you
increase the creativity
but turn it into a process like
literally
like don't do it accidentally you know
like
uh like an athlete
does certain things to optimize their
performance they have a training routine
they have a regimen of uh
of like cycling and and uh sprints and
long distance stuff in the same way
thinking about your
job as an idea generator in engineering
space it's like this is good for my
performance so like for an hour before
bed
think through a problem like every night
and then
use sleep to uh
work through that problem i mean that
he's the first person that i heard like
of the people i really respect that do
like what i do which is like programming
engineering type work
like using
sleep not accidentally but with a
purpose
like using sleep
you know that's just basically the
difference between as you said a passive
approach to it versus
you know an
an active deterministic or hope for a
deterministic approach to it in other
words that you are actually trying to
harness the power of of sleep in a
deliberate way rather than an
unthoughtful way i still think that you
know mother nature
through it you know 3.6 million years of
evolution has probably got it
mostly figured out in terms of what
information should be uploaded at night
and worked through i think her algorithm
is probably pretty good at this stage
it's not to suggest though that you know
we can't try to tweak it and nudge it
you know it's a very light hand on the
tiller is is what he's doing i i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
you know just like for example for me
fasting has improved my ability to focus
deeply and productivity significantly
and in that same way
you know it's possible that playing with
these ideas of thinking before bed or
some hours before better some
playing with different protocols will
have a significant leap over what mother
nature naturally does so if you let your
body do what it naturally does you may
not achieve the same level of
performance because mother nature
has not designed us to think deeply
about uh chip design
for uh programming artificial
intelligence systems so well she's
gifted us the architecture and the
capacity to do that
what we do with that is
you know is what life's experience
dictates
she gives us the blueprint to do many
you know well if i were to sort of
introspect and self analyze what mother
nature wants me to do i think given my
current lifestyle that i have food in
the fridge
and a bed to sleep on i think what
mother nature wants me to do is to be
lazy
and so i think i'm actually resisting
mother nature uh
in
because so many of my knees are
satisfied and so i i'm
i have to resist some of the natural
forces of the body and the mind when i
do some of the things i do so there's
that dance
um you know like i've been thinking
about doing a startup and that's
obviously going against everything that
my body and mind
are telling me to do because it's going
to be basically suffering
but the only reason i want as you know
it will be over
yes
i but nevertheless there's some kind of
inner drive that wants me to do it and
then you start to ask a question well
how do you optimize the things you can't
optimize like sleep like diet like the
people that you surround yourself with
in order to
maximize happiness and performance and
all those kinds of things without also
over optimizing and that's such an
interesting idea from
from a
engineer so
as you may know you don't often
get that those kinds of ideas from
engineers engineers usually just
don't read books about sleeping
they're usually like the the
they're not they they're not the
healthiest of people
um
i think that's changing over time
especially silicon valley especially the
tech sector people are starting to
understand what's a healthy lifestyle
but usually they're kind of on the
insane side especially programmers but
it's nice to hear uh somebody like that
use sleep and use some of the things you
talk about strategically yeah
on purpose
you know to that idea of
not just
trying to use what mother nature gave
but
seeing if you can do something more or
different
in a conservative mindset
i would then pose the question at what
cost
because when you
do something perhaps that deviates from
the typical pre-programmed
you know
mother nature's program
i suspect it usually comes at the cost
of something else so maybe he is you
know able to direct and focus
his sleeping cognition
on those particular topics that will
gain him better problematic resolution
the next day when he wakes up the
question is though at what cost of the
other things that didn't make it onto
the menu
of
the finger buffet of sleep that night
and is it that you don't process the
emotional
difficulties or events and therefore you
are less emotionally resolved the next
day but you are more problem resolved
the following day and so i always try to
think and
i truly don't want to sound puritanical
either about sleep and i think i've come
off that way
many a time especially when i started
out in the public
the tone of the book in some ways you
know i look back and think could i have
been a little softer
and the reason was i i was that way
back in when i started writing the book
which was probably something like
2014 or 15.
sleep was the neglected stepsister in
the health conversation of the day
and i was just so sad to see the amount
of suffering and disease and sickness
that was caused by insufficient sleep
and for years before i've been you know
doing public speaking and i'd tell
people about the great things that
happen when you get sleep people would
say that's fascinating and then they
would go back and keep doing the same
thing about not sleeping enough and then
i realized you can't really speak about
the good things that happen it's like
the news what bleeds leads and if you
speak about the alarmingly bad things
that happen people tend to have a
behavioral change
and so the book as a consequence i think
probably came out a little bit on the
strong side of
you know trying to convince you know
people you're trying to help a lot of
people and that's a powerful way to help
a lot of people i would i was genuinely
trying to help people but you know
certainly for some people who for whom
sleep is not does not come easy then it
was probably you know
a tricky book to read too and i think i
i feel more sensitive to those people
now and empathetically connected to them
um
so i think the again the point was
simply that i don't mean to sound too
puritanical in in all of this and the
same way with
you know caffeine and coffee
i am just a scientist and i am not here
to tell anyone how to live their life
that is not my job at all and life is to
be lived to a degree and life is to be
lived if you want to do a startup
all i want to do is empower people with
the understanding of the science of
sleep and then you can make an informed
choice as to how you want to live your
life and i often no judgement on how
anyone wishes to live their life i just
want to try and
see if the information that i have about
sleep would alternatively change how you
would think about your life decisions
and if it doesn't no problem and if it
does i hope it's been of use well
maybe this is me trying to justify my
lifestyle to you
but
dr seuss said
you know you're in love when you can't
fall asleep because reality is finally
better than your dreams
i love that quote too
okay
my sleeping uh schedule is uh
complicated
and it has to do primarily
with the fact that i love
basically everything that i do
and that love takes a form that may not
appear
to be love from the external observer
perspective because it often includes
struggle it often includes
something that looks like stress even
though it's not stress it's like this
excitement it's this
turmoil and chaos of passion
of struggling with the problem of being
sad and down
to the point even depressed of how
difficult the problem is the
disappointment that the last few weeks
and months have been a failure and
self-doubt all that
mix but i i love it and a part of that
is sometimes staying up all night
working on a thing i'm really passionate
about
and that means sleep schedules that are
just like
you know
sometimes sleeping during the day
sometimes very often
sleeping very little but taking naps
that are like an hour or two hours or so
on that kind of weird chaos and yeah now
i'll also try to get
give myself back up i was trying to like
research yesterday is anybody else
productive wild like this and there's of
course a lot of anecdotal evidence and
some of it
could be just narratives that people
have told to the public when in reality
they sleep way more but there's a bunch
of people that
you know have not are famous for not
sleeping much so
uh on the topic of naps
uh this i read this a long time ago and
i checked this churchill was big on
big naps
and is actually just reading more about
winston churchill's sleep schedule is
very much like mine
so i basically want to give myself the
opportunity to at night to stay up all
night if i want to
and a good nap is a big part of that in
the late evening like how often does
this destroy social life completely but
i i'll often take a nap in the late
afternoon or the evening and that sets
me if i want to stay up all night yeah
and things like that like uh the i've
read that nikola tesla slept only two
hours a night edison the same three
hours
but he actually did uh the polyphasic
sleep like where's just a bunch of naps
what
can you say
about this madness of love and passion
of loving everything you do
and uh the chaos of sleep that might
result in
i love the seuss quote um and
i've had that experience too like you
i
adore what i do you know if
if someone you know gave you you know
enough money to to live the rest of your
life you know i've got a roof above my
head rice and beans on the table um and
they said you don't have to work anymore
i would do nothing different i i would
do exactly you know
this sounds a little crass and i hope it
doesn't sound this way but
being a scientist
is not what i do it's who i am
when that's the case
sleep working out
showering and eating
are the things that i do in between
my love of fur
with sleep
yeah i fell for sleep like a blind
roofer
and
and it was a love affair that started 20
years ago and i remain utterly besotted
today
it's the most beguiling thing
in the world to me
and i could easily and i have you know
it's kept me up at night
when my mind is fizzing with
experimental ideas or i think i've got a
new hypothesis or theory
i will struggle with sleep
i really will it it doesn't come easy to
me because my mind is just so on fire
with those
ideas so i understand the the struggle
but you know i couldn't advocate from a
scientific perspective the schedule
because the science just doesn't
you know i would feel
as though i'm doing you a disservice to
say
it's okay you know that that won't come
with
some blast radius some you know health
consequences you know you can add
margaret thatcher and ronald reagan to
that list too both of them were very
you know proud chess beaters of how
little sleep that they get thatcher said
four hours reagan something similar you
know and i knowing the links that we now
know between sleep and alzheimer's
disease i've often wondered whether it
was coincidental then that both of them
died of the terrible disease of
alzheimer's meaning you know maybe it
doesn't get you by way of you know being
popped out of the gene pool in a car
accident because you had a microsleep at
the wheel at age 32 or it doesn't get
you at
42 with you know heart attack or even 52
with cancer or a stroke maybe it gets
you in your 70s yeah i think the elastic
band of sleep deprivation can stretch
only so far before it snaps
and it ultimately seems to snap you know
nicole tesla uh
i think he um
goes to see he i think died of a
coronary thrombosis i believe
and there was a wonderful study done out
of harvard where they took a group of
people who had no signs of
cardiovascular disease
and what they found is that when they
tracked them
for years afterwards
they were completely healthy to begin
with those people who are getting less
than six hours of sleep ended up having
a 300
increased risk of developing
calcification of the coronary artery
which is the major
sort of
corridor of life for your heart when
someone says you know he died of a
massive coronary it's because of a
blockade of the coronary artery
you know and and tesla you know passed
away from
a coronary thrombosis we also know that
insufficient sleep is linked to numerous
mental health issues we know that
churchill had a wicked battle with
depression gosh my goodness he used to
call it black dog that would come and
visit him
and i think many of his paintings he was
exquisite painter but some of them would
depict his darkness with depression as
well
you know edison is interesting people
have argued that he would short sleep
and he didn't put much value in sleep
whether or not that's true we don't know
but he was a habitual nappy you're right
during the day i've got some great
pictures of him on his inventor's bench
taking a nap in fact i believe he set up
nap cops around his house yeah so he
could nap
but what we also know a study again
coming out of harvard just
a couple of months ago demonstrated very
clearly that polyphasic sleep is
associated with worse physical outcomes
worth cognitive outcomes and especially
worse mood outcomes so from that sense
you know sleeping like a baby is not
perfect for adults
there's a
fascinating dance here
of uh
the mean and the extreme like the
the average and the high performers
so i um
this this gets to like the meaning of
life kind of discussion but
let's go then
so well and also happiness so
when studying sleep and we're studying
anything like diet and exercise i think
you have to really get a lot more data
about individuals to make
a conclusive statement that's when
people talk about like is meat red meat
good for your bad for you right
it's just so often correlated with other
life decisions
when you choose to eat meat or not
my
my sense
is that
whatever life decisions you make if they
reduce stress and lead to happiness
that's also going to be a big boost that
needs to be integrated into the plots in
the science right so
the i'll give you an example of somebody
who is unarguably seen as unhealthy
my friend mr david goggins
so
he's clearly obviously almost on purpose
destroying his body
like and to say that he's doing the
wrong thing or the unhealthy thing
feels
feels like
feels wrong yeah
and
but i'm not sure exactly in which way he
feels wrong one of the things i'm
bothered by and
again i apologize for the therapy
sessions uh
a framework of this but
i'm bothered by
the fact that a lot of people tell me
or david that they're doing things wrong
a lot of people in my life when they see
me not sleep
they'll tell me to sleep more
now they're correct
but
one fundamental aspect that i'd like to
complain about
is not enough people almost nobody
especially people that care for me
will come to me and say
you have a dream
work harder
like
it's like
the healthy thing should be a component
of a life well lived right but not um
not everything and i don't know what to
do with that because uh you certainly
don't want to espouse and just like you
said when you were working in your book
there is uh a belief you know
sleep was a secondary citizen in in the
full spectrum of what's a healthy life
but at the same time i'm bothered by in
silicon valley and all these kinds of
uh work environments that i get to work
with with engineers is there's
to me too much focus on work-life
balance
what that usually starts meaning is like
yeah yeah of course it's good to have a
social life it's good to have a family
it's good to it's good to
eat well and sleep well but we should
also discover our passion we should also
give our chance
to uh give give ourself a chance to work
our ass off towards a dream
and make mistakes and take big risks
that in the short term seem to sacrifice
health and i think you know you to come
back to how you started about david
goggins who i've never met but who i
admire
incredibly and have an immense reverence
for the man um
you said
two things is it
is it wrong to do those things
to yourself
and is it unhealthy to do those things
i disagree with the former and i agree
with the latter
so from a health biological medicine
perspective
sleeping in the way that you know you've
described or that other people may be
sleeping in terms of insufficient
amounts
you know science now to your point too
about inter-individual differences
usually when i see a bar graph and a
mean i usually say show me your variance
yeah i want to see your variants in
other words show me the distribution of
that effect how many people were below
the mean how many is it all tightly
clustered around this one thing so it's
a very robust effect or was this huge
fan of effect where for some people
there was no effect at all on other
people there was a whopping effect and
everything in between
so i don't discount into individual
variability
but
and i will come back to those two points
about is it wrong and is it unhealthy in
just a second when it comes to sleep we
have found huge amounts of
inter-individual differences in your
response to a lack of sleep
but one of the fascinating things so
let's say that i take you and we're
going to measure your attention your
emotion your mood your blood pressure
your blood sugar glucose regulation your
autonomic nervous system and your
different gene expression let's say i'm
just going to measure a whole you know
kaleidoscope of different outcomes brain
and body
and i find that on our measure of
cognition on your attentional ability to
focus you are very resilient you just
don't show any impairment at all even
after being awake for 36 hours straight
does that mean that you are resilient in
all of those other domains as well the
answer is no you're not
so you can be resilient in one
but
very vulnerable in another and we've
we've not found anyone who isn't at
least vulnerable in one of those domains
meaning that
it's somewhat safe to say that
not getting sufficient sleep will lead
to some kind of impairment in any one
given individual it may not be the same
impermanent
but it's likely to be an impairment but
to come back to the question i think
it's wrong to tell anyone that it's
wrong to do what they're doing even if
they are compromising their sleep even
if they're compromising their mental
health you know as long as they're not
hurting anyone else
then i think
the answer is that's that person's
choice
yeah but that's that person i'd like to
push back further so you see the way you
kind of said it
yes you're absolutely right
but
i would like to say a stronger statement
which is you should let go of that
judgment of somebody is wrong
and allow yourself to be inspired by the
great heights they have reached
so
take yourself out of the seat of being a
judger of what is healthy and not and
appreciate the greatness of a particular
human you you watch the olympics the
kind of things that some athletes do to
reach the very heights
the olympics are taking years off their
life
they they suffer depression after the
olympics often there it's the physiology
disastrous yeah everything their
personal life there's
their psychology their physiology
um everything it's a giant mess so the
question is about life
you know healthy
now
means you know longevity
quality of life over a prolonged period
of time
you know optimal performance over a
prolonged period of time but to me
beauty
is reaching great heights
and there's a dance there
that sometimes reaching great heights
requires sacrifice of health and not
like
a calculation where you sat down on a
sheet of paper and say i'm going to take
seven years off my life for an olympic
gold medal right no it requires more
chaotic journey
that that doesn't do that kind of
calculus and i just want to kind of
speak to the
in the culture that struggles of what is
healthy and not we want to be able to uh
speak to what is healthy and at the same
time be inspired by the great heights
that humans reach no matter how healthy
or unhealthy they uh they live yeah i
agree with that i think if that's a flag
you're hoisting i will definitely salute
it because it really depends you know
what are you trying to optimize for in
your life
and if you are
i think the only danger potentially with
that mindset is that
if you look at many of the studies of
old age and end of life
most people say i never look back on my
life
and
wish i worked harder
i wish instead i'd spent more time
with family friends
and engaged in that aspect now i'm not
saying though coming back to your point
that that is the standard rubric for
everyone i don't believe it is too and
there are many things that you and i are
both benefiting from today even in the
field of medicine
where people have sacrificed their own
longevity
for the quest of solving a particular
medical problem
and they died
quicker because of their commitment
because they wished to try and solve
that problem in their pursuit of
greatness scientifically and i now
benefit am i grateful that they did that
incredibly grateful
you know it's a simpler demonstration of
is this if tonight at 4 am in the
morning
i have
a ruptured appendix
i have an appendicitis
i am incredibly grateful that there is
an emergency
team that will take me to the hospital
at 4am in the morning they are awake
they're not sleeping and they save my
life
and that is the
that's part of what their life's mission
and quest is and they saved another's
life by
in some ways shaving a little of their
own off
so i don't take i have no umbrage uh
with that mentality at all i think you
just have to be very clear about what
you're optimizing for
and my worry is that most people fall
into the rat race
and they never actually ask the question
why am i doing this if you're just
working nine to five
or uh and you allow that nine to five to
stretch into much longer but it's
nevertheless a job that's kind of like
wears you down that's one thing another
thing is when
it is a like you're
it's a it's a dream
it's a life mission accomplish and and
for that
i think as long as you know
what it is that you could be doing to
yourself and you are comfortable and
a-okay with that
i
this i have no problem with that at all
again as i said as a scientist i cannot
should not and will not tell anyone what
they should do with their life all i
want you to be able to do is say okay
now i understand more about the
previously these were the you know
known unknowns and these were the
unknown unknowns
and now i am slightly more cognizant i
have more knowns than
than i had before
regarding my sleep and my health knowing
that information do i still choose
to make this decision
and
if that's what i offered
then i think i've done my job that's all
i want to offer is just added
information into the decision algorithm
and what you end up choosing as an
output of that algorithm has nothing to
do with me it's not my business and i
will never judge anyone for it and as i
said i'm immensely grateful for people
who have sacrificed
much in their lives to give me what i
have so you're saying as long as the
sacrifice sort of grounded in knowledge
of
you know what the sacrifice is that that
sleep is important and that you're
comfortable with it that is it is your
conscious choice rather than feeling as
though you're trapped or that you are
just you haven't thought about it and
you know you start that job at age 32
and then you wake up the next morning
and you're 65 and you think where did my
life go what was i doing
that to me i would feel i would want to
hug you and i would say i'm so i'm just
so and i'm not sending i don't want to
sound belittling here at all
i would just not wish that for you i
would wish that you
could have
you know
thought about what it was that you're
doing and not have that regret yeah so i
guess i'm uh this is for you the
listener i'm coming out of the closet
here a little bit the fact that i enjoy
the madness i live in so please do not
criticize me embrace me i i understand
the sacrifices i'm making i enjoy
sleeping on the floor when i'm
passionately programming all night and
just pass out on
on on the carpet
i i love this life okay so it's it's uh
it but it's definitely something i think
about that
there's a balance of strike uh
where i just want you to have as much of
it though
of life
see
quality of life is important
i should have said i want you to have as
much high quality life and if high
quality of life means
i spend five decades on this planet
but yet in that time i am thrilled every
day i'm turned on every day by what i do
and i
reveled
in this thing called my life's work
i think that that is a
50-year journey of absolute
delight and fulfillment that you should
take
i i think about my death all the time i
meditate on death
i'm okay to die today
so to me longevity is not um
it's not it's not a significant goal i'm
so happy to be alive
i don't even think it would suck to die
uh today i i'm i'm as afraid of it today
as i will be in 50 years
i don't want to die as much today as i
will in 50 years there's uh
there's of course all these experiences
i would like to have but
i'm everything's already amazing it's
like the lego movie so i i don't know so
i to me i just want to keep doing this
and um
there's there's of course
things that could affect you know like
you mentioned dementia and these uh
deterioration of the the mind or the
body that can significantly affect
the uh the quality of life right and so
you want to uh as you're aware of that
and you know that's the price you pay
for the entry of into this magical you
know
kingdom that you are experiencing which
is a lovely thing you know i i feel
privileged too to i can't believe the
life that i live it's
incredible
and just like you i don't
i do i do i think about mortality a
great deal i think a lot about death but
i don't worry about
death i i probably
with the exception of the potential pain
that comes before it that some people
many people can't suffer
that maybe concerns me but i actually
think about mortality as a tool as i use
it as a lens through which
i can then retrospect
and by placing myself at the point of
future mortality i can then use it as a
retrospective
lens to focus and ask the following
question is that anything i feel i would
regret
and therefore change in the life that i
currently have now
i that's the way i meditate and use
mortality as a question
is to try and course correct and focus
my life
i worry not about dying
yeah
but i like to think about death as a way
to prioritize my life
if that makes sense i don't know if that
makes sense no it makes total sense to
decide
how do you want to live today so that
in the future you do not regret the way
you live today right and to place
yourself in the future at your point of
mortality is one way to i think as an
exercise to retrospectively look
back
and
not lose out on informed choices that
you could otherwise lose out lose out on
if you weren't thinking about mortality
yeah it cl it clarifies your thinking uh
is there um so i mentioned i sleep on
the floor take naps and power naps and
it's just kind of madness is there uh
weirdness as to your own sleep schedule
as a scientist that
does incredible work has a lot of things
going on
has has to lead research has to write
research has to be a science
communicator also have a social life all
those kinds of things is there
certain
patterns to your own sleep that you
regret
or you um
or you participate in
uh that you you find you enjoy
um like is is there some like personal
stuff uh quirks or things you're proud
of that you do in terms of your sleep
schedule
the funny thing about
being a sleep researcher is that it
doesn't make you immune right to the
ravages of a difficult night of sleep
and i have
battled my own periods of insomnia in my
life too
and i think i've been fortunate in ways
because i know how sleep works and i
know how to combat insomnia i know how
to get it under control
because insomnia in many ways
is a condition where all of a sudden
your sleep controls you
rather than you control your sleep well
yeah that's a beautiful way to put it
yeah
and
i
know when i'm starting to
lose control and it's starting to take
control
and i understand how to
regain but i've it doesn't happen now
overnight it takes a long time
so you've struggled with insomnia in
your life
i have not not all of my life i would
say i've probably had three or four
really severe bouts and all of them
usually triggered by you know emotional
circumstances by stress
um stress that's connected to actual
events in life or stress that's
unexplainable
will
externally triggered yeah it's sort of
what we would call reactive stress
um
and
so that that's sort of point number one
about the idiosyncrasies the point
number two is that when you are having a
difficult night of sleep
as a sleep researcher you basically have
become the woody allen neurotic of the
sleep world
because at that moment you know i'm
trying to fall asleep and i'm not and
i'm starting to think okay my
dorsilateral prefrontal cortex is not
shutting down my noradrenaline is not
ramping down my sympathetic nervous
system is not giving way to my parasite
at that point you are dead in the water
for the next two hours and nothing is
bringing you back so uh there is some
irony in that too i would say for myself
though i
if there's something i'm not proud of it
has been
at times railing against my chronotype
so your chronotype is essentially are
you a morning type evening type or
somewhere in between yeah
and
there were times because society is
desperately biased towards the morning
types
you know this notion of the early bird
catches the worm
maybe that's true but i'll also tell you
that the second mouse gets the cheese
yeah so i think one of my issues
around
you know is firstly people don't really
understand cronotype
because i'll have some people when i'm
sort of out in the public they'll say
look i struggle with terrible insomnia
and i'll ask them is it problems falling
asleep or staying asleep and they'll say
falling asleep
and then i'll say look if you are on a
desert island with nothing to wake up
for no responsibilities what time would
you normally go to bed and what time
would you wake up and they would say i'd
probably like to go to bed about
midnight and wake up maybe eight in the
morning then i'd say so what time do you
now go to bed and they'd say well i've
got to be up for work early so i get
into bed at 10.
i say well you don't have insomnia you
have a mismatch between your biological
chronotype and your current sleep
schedule and when you align those two
and i was fighting that for some time
too i'm
probably
mostly right in the middle i am
desperately vanilla
unfortunately in many aspects of life
but this included i'm neither a strong
morning type nor a strong evening type
so ideally i'd probably like to go to
bed around you know 11 10 30 11 probably
somewhere between 10 13 11 and wake up
you know i naturally wake up usually
most days before my alarm at um 704
um
and it's 704 because
why not be idiosyncratic in terms of
sitting i love it um
and so
i that's kind of awesome i've never
heard about that that's that's amazing
i'm going to start doing that now
setting alarms like a little bit off the
like
yeah i know i'm never quite sure why
we're the celebration of uniqueness
yeah and i am quite the the odd
snowflake in that sense too um
so i would usually then try to force
myself because i had that same mentality
that if i wasn't up at you know
6 13 in the gym by seven
that there was something wrong with me
and
i quickly abandoned that but if i look
back if there was a shameful act that i
have around my sleep i think it would be
that for some years until i really
started to get more detailed into sleep
and now i have no shame in telling
people that you know i
will probably usually wake up around 6
45 naturally sometimes seven
um when people are looking at me
thinking you're a sloth you're lazy um
and you know i don't finish my daily
workout until you know i'm not working
until probably nine o'clock in the
morning i'm thinking what are you doing
now i will work late into the
day you know if i could i would work 16
hours that's my passion just like yours
um
so i don't feel shame around that but i
have changed my mentality around that
um it's complicated because i um
i'm
probably happiest going to bed at if i'm
being honest like at 5 00 a.m that's
fine you're just an extreme evening time
but
the problem is
it's not that i'm ashamed for it it's uh
i actually kind of enjoy it because i
get to sleep through all the nonsense of
like the morning and
isn't that a beautiful thing like people
are busy with their emails and and i
just am a happy as a cow yeah and i wake
up after all the drama has been resolved
yeah and cows are happy and the drama
has been resolved exactly so i but you
know in society you do especially i mean
this is what i think about is um
you know when you work on a larger team
especially with companies
you are
you know everybody's awake at the same
time so
that that's definitely that's definitely
been a struggle to try to figure out
just like you said um how to balance
that how to fit into society and yet be
optimal for your chronotype
yup
you have to sleep in synchrony with it
and harmony
um because normally what we know
is that if you fight biology
you'll normally lose and the way you
know you've lost is through disease and
sickness
you said you suffered through several
bouts of insomnia
is there
aside from embracing your chronotype
is there um advice you can give how to
overcome insomnia from your own
experience
right now the best method that we have
is something called cognitive behavioral
therapy for insomnia or cbti for short
and you work with for people who don't
know what it is you work with a
therapist for maybe six weeks and you
can do it online by the way i
recommend probably jumping online it's
just easiest
and it will change your
beliefs your habits your behaviors and
your general stress around this thing
called sleep and it is just as effective
as sleeping pills in the short term
but what's great is that unlike sleeping
pills when you stop working with your
therapist those benefits last for years
later whereas when you stop your
sleeping pills you typically have what's
called rebound insomnia where your sleep
not only goes back to being as bad as it
was before it's usually even worse
for me i think i found a number of
things effective
the first is that i had to really
address what was
stressful and try to come up with
some degree of meaningful
rationality around it
because i think one of the things that
happens there's something very talking
about conscious states to come all the
way back to um gosh i don't know i feel
like we've only been chatting for like
20 minutes but you're going to tell me
it's been a while it's been a while okay
and desperately i'm i feel like terribly
sorry okay but let's come back to
consciousness
where we started yeah um there is
something very strange about the night
that thoughts and anxieties
are not the same as they are in the
waking day they are worse they are
bigger and i at least find that i am
far
more
likely to catastrophize and ruminate
at night about things that when i wake
up the next day in the broad light of
day i think
it's nowhere near that bad man what were
you doing it's not that bad at all
so to gain firstly some rational
understanding of my emotional state
that's causing that insomnia was very
helpful
the second thing was to keep regularity
just going to bed at the same time
waking up and here's an unconventional
piece of sleep advice
after a bad night of sleep
do
nothing
don't wake up any later
don't go to bed any earlier
don't nap during the day
and don't drink any more coffee than you
would otherwise
because if you end up sleeping later
into the the morning
you're then not going to be tired at
your normal time at night so then you're
going to get into bed thinking well i
had a terrible night of sleep last night
and yes i slept in this morning to try
and compensate but i'm still going to
get to bed at my normal time but now you
get into bed and you haven't been awake
for as long as you normally would so
you're not asleepy as you normally would
be and so now you sit there lying in bed
and it's another bad night
and the same thing is you know if you go
to bed any earlier
so don't wake up any later
wake up at the same time don't go to bed
any earlier because then you're just
probably your chronotype your biological
rhythm doesn't want you to be asleep and
you think well a terrible night i'm
going to get into bed at 9 00 pm rather
than my standard 10 you're just going to
be lying in bed awake for that hour
naps will take our double-edged sword
they can have wonderful benefits we've
done lots of studies on naps for both
the brain and the body
but they are a double-edged sword in the
sense that
napping
will just take the edge off your
sleepiness it's a little bit like a
valve on a pressure cooker when you nap
during the day
you can take some of that healthy
sleepiness that you've been building up
during the day and for some people not
all people but for some people that can
then make it harder for them to fall
asleep at night and then stay asleep
soundly across the night
so the advice would be if you're
struggling with sleep at night don't nap
during the day
but if you are not struggling with sleep
and you can nap regularly naps are just
fine
and we can play around with optimal
durations depending on what you want
just try not to nap too late into the
day because napping late into the day is
like snacking before your main meal yeah
it just takes the edge off your sleep
hunger as it were but that would be um
so that's my unconventional
second piece of advice regarding
insomnia
the third is meditation i found
meditation to be incredibly powerful i
started reading about meditation as i
was researching that aspect of the book
um many years ago
and as a hard-nosed scientist i thought
this sounds very woo-woo um this is sort
of
we all hold hands and sing come by and
everything's going to be fine with sleep
i read the data and it was compelling i
couldn't ignore it
and i started meditating and that was
six years ago and i haven't stopped
and i find meditation before bed
incredibly powerful
the meditation app companies were
perplexed at this at first they want
people to meditate during the day but
when they looked at their usage
statistics they found that they would
have people in the morning meditating
and then there's a huge number of people
using the meditation app in the evening
what they were doing was self-medicating
this their insomnia and they finally
rather than railing against it they
started to see it as a cash cow
rightly so yeah so i found meditation to
be helpful having a wind down routine is
the other thing that's critical for me
i can't just go from because when my
mind is switched on and i think you may
be like this too
if i get into bed
that roller decks of thoughts and
information and excitement and anxiety
and worry is just
whirling away
and it's not going to be a good night
for me so i have to find a wind down
routine and that makes sense when you
realize what sleep is like sleep is not
like a light switch
sleep is much more like trying to land a
plane
you know it takes time to descend down
onto the terra firma that we call sound
sleep at night
and we have this for kids you know i
don't have children but you know
a lot of parents will say
you know we have to have the bedroom
sorry the bedtime routine you know you
bathe the kids you put them in bed you
read them a story you have to go through
this routine this wind down routine for
them and then they fall asleep
wonderfully
why do we abandon that
as adults we need that same wind down
routine
so
that's been the other thing that's been
very helpful to me so um don't do
anything different if you have a bad
night of sleep keep doing the same thing
manage your anxiety understand it
rationalize it
then meditation
and then finally having some kind of
disengagement wind down routine
those are the four things that have been
very helpful to me that's brilliant so
the the regularities really do a lot of
a lot of work against insomnia is there
um
is it possible to have a healthy
sleep life
without the regularities
i say that
because i'm all over the place yeah and
i've gotten good in being all over the
place
so i'll often like what happens i'll go
stretches of time there'll be sometimes
a month where i my days are like this is
embarrassing to admit but
they're like just you and i here
just you and i it's like 28 hours or 30
hour days yeah
like i'll just go all the way around
comfortably and happily i love it and
now there'll be a nap i mean if you like
add up the hours
when i'm just like sleeping as much
as i want it'll probably be like six
hour average per 24 hours
like that kind of yeah so it works out
nicely maybe even seven hours i don't
know but
that it's obviously irregular and
there's chaos in the whole thing right
like
sometimes it's shorter sleeve sometimes
it's longer is that
is that totally not a good thing do you
think
the best evidence that we have to speak
to this question is people who are doing
rotating shifts
and
unfortunately the news is not good um
they usually have a higher incidence of
many diseases such as
depression diabetes cardiovascular
disease obesity
um
stroke and
[Music]
and again i'm
that's just me communicating the data
that we we have and i'm not telling you
that you should do anything different
the other
thing is that there's nothing in your
biology
that suggests that that's how your body
was designed to sleep
um it is a system that
loves habit you know
if
if your circadian clock in your brain
it's called the suprachiasmatic nucleus
um sits in the middle of your brain
had a personality trait it would be a
creature of habit
it loves habit that's how your biology
is designed to work is through very
archetypal prototypical expected cycles
and
when we when we do something different
to that then
you start to see some of the pressure
stress fractures in the system
but again
to your point
if that's something that you don't mind
you know
adopting and understanding and um
then i think you should keep doing what
you're doing it's complicated you of
course have to be a student of your own
body and explore it one of the reasons i
want to have kids
is kids in forces a stricter schedule
i i think i definitely i've had
i i definitely feel that i'm um
not living the
sort of data wise scientifically
speaking the optimal life
and me just living the way i want to
live day to day is perhaps not the
optimal way and there's certain things
that i've seen very successful people
that i
know in my life when they get when they
have kids
they actually their productivity goes up
they get their [ __ ] together there's a
lot of aspects that everything yeah yeah
the regularity i mean that creature is a
habit that's the thing that that that's
power and then you start to optimally
use the hours you have in the day let me
ask you about actually i just have one
quick point on that too you know we
often think about
sleep as a cost
but instead i think of sleep as an
investment
and the reason is because your
effectiveness and your efficiency when
you're well slept
typically exceeds that when you're not
and to me it's the idea of if i'm going
to boil a pot of water
why would i boil it
on medium when i could boil it in half
the time on high
yeah and i sometimes worry that when i
speak to fortune 500 companies and you
know they're of this mentality of
you know longer hours getting people to
rise and grind
the first point is that after about 20
hours of being awake a human being is as
cognitively as impaired as they would be
if they were legally drunk
and
the reason i bring that point up is
because i don't know any
company or ceo who would say
i've got this great team they're drunk
all the time
but we often
lord the airport warrior who's flown
through three different time zones in
the past two days is on email at 2am and
then is you know in the office at six
and i think there is some aspect not in
all people but there is sort of some
aspect of that slight sleep machismo
and and that's not what you are very
different you know you are driven by
a purity of passion and a very authentic
incredibly genuine goal of wanting to do
something remarkable with your life
that's not the issue i think i'm i'm
speaking about
it's just simply that i think the
this notion of wanting to be awake for
longer to try and get more done
right can sometimes be at odds with the
fact that
you can actually get so much more done
if you're well slept and it's this
trade-off
i actually admire people that take the
big risk and work hard whether that
means staying up late at night all those
kinds of things
but it cannot be in the in the framework
in the context like what edison said
which is sleep feels like a waste of
time
so like if you're not sleeping
because you think sleep is stupid that's
totally wrong
but if you're not sleeping because
you're deeply passionate about something
that to me it's a it's a gray area
of course but that to me is much more
admirable and it's everything you're
espousing is saying like whatever the
hell you're doing you better be aware
that sleep
long term and short term is really good
for you
so if you're not sleeping you're
sacrificing just make sure you're
sacrificing for the right thing
i i see vodka and getting drunk the same
way
i know it's not good for me i know i'm
not gonna feel good
days after i know it's gonna decrease my
performance and there's nothing positive
about it except
it introduces chaos in my life
that
introduces beautiful experiences that i
would not otherwise have it uh
creates like this uh
turmoil of social interaction that
ultimately
makes me happy that i've experienced
them in the moment and later at the
stories you get to meet new people it's
like alcohol in this society is is a
an incredible facilitator of that so
like that's a good example of like not
sleeping and drinking way too much vodka
again it's this notion of you know life
is to be lived to
a degree but you know if you do have
children um
i think one of the other things that
then maybe comes into the picture is the
fact that now
there are other people that you have to
live for
than yourself
yeah but come on like once they're old
enough like if you can't if you can't
defend for yourself you're you're too
weak get stronger it's going to be that
kind of fatherhood yeah i got it
i i'm understanding so much more about
lex friedman than uh
that's why you have to have
your uh for for me that'd be my wife
would be probably softer it's good cop
bad cop because i think
but of course actually because i don't
have kids i've seen some tough dudes
when they have
kids become this the the like the
softest the softies they become like
they they do everything for their kids
it becomes like it totally transforms
their life i mean joe rogan is an
example of that
i just seen so many tough guys
completely become changed
by having kids which is fascinating to
watch because it just shows you how
meaningful having kids is for a lot of
people although i would say having
you know um
chatted with joe for for some time um i
think he is a delightful sweetheart
independent of children i think
don't get me wrong i don't want to be in
a ring with him
he would face me five ways till tuesday
but um i think he's a desperately sweet
man and a very very smart individual
yeah i mean but he talks about the
compassion he's gained from realizing
just watching kids grow up that we were
all kids at some point you you get a new
new perspective i think just like me i
still get this uh with him he's super
competitive and like there's a certain
way to approach life
like you're striving to do great things
and you're competitive against others
and that intensity or that aggression
um that
can lack compassion sometimes in empathy
and when you have children you get
a sense like oh everybody was a child at
some point everybody was as a kid and
you see that whole development process
it can definitely enrich
um expand
your your
ability to be empathetic
let me ask you about diet
so what's the connection between diet
and sleep
so i do intermittent fasting sometimes
only one meal a day sometimes no meals a
day
is there a good science on the
interaction between
fasting and sleep
we have some data i would prefer more
but we have data both on
time restricted eating
and then
we have some data on
fasting to a
on time restricted eating
i think that it has some benefits
although the human replication studies
have actually not borne out quite the
same health benefit extent that the
animal studies have been some
disappointing
studies one here close to where we are
right now at ucsf recently
so i think time restricted eating can be
a good thing and there are many benefits
of time restricted eating is sleep one
of them no it doesn't seem to be
because there are probably at the time
that we're recording this three pretty
decent studies that i'm aware of
um two out of the three were in obese
individuals one out of the three were in
healthy weight individuals and what they
found was that time restricted eating in
all three of those studies didn't have
any advantageous benefit to sleep it
didn't necessarily harm sleep but it
didn't seem to improve it
when it comes to fasting though which is
a different state
we don't have too many studies
experimental studies with long-term
fasting the best data that we have is
probably from religious practices and
probably the most data we have is during
ramadan where people will fast for 29 to
30 days from sunrise to sunset
and under those conditions
there are probably
are probably five distinct changes that
we've seen
none of them seem to be particularly
good for sleep the first is that the
amount of melatonin that you release a
melatonin is a hormone it's often called
the hormone of darkness
or the vampire hormone not because it
makes you look longingly at people's
necklines but it's just because it comes
out at night yeah melatonin signals to
your brain that and your body that it's
dark it's nighttime and it's time to
sleep
those individuals when they were
undergoing that regiment of fasting
they
the amount of melatonin that was
released and when it was released the
amount of melatonin decreased
and
when it was released came later that was
the first thing the second thing was
that
they ended up finding it harder to fall
asleep as quickly as they normally would
otherwise
the third thing was that the total
amount of sleep that they were getting
decreased
the fourth fascinating thing was that a
wake promoting chemical called erectin
increased and this is why a lot of
people will say when i'm fasting it
feels like i can stay awake for longer
and i can i'm more alert i'm more active
and i'll come back to from an
evolutionary perspective why we
understand that to be the case
and then the fourth factor is that
fasting didn't decrease the amount of
deep sleep that seemed to be unaffected
it did however decrease the amount of
rem sleep or dream sleep and we know
that rem sleep dreaming is essential for
emotional first aid mental health it's
critical for memory creativity it's also
critical for several hormone functions
it's when you know if you there's direct
correlations between testosterone you
know testosterone release peaks just
before you go into rem sleep and during
rem sleep too
so rem sleep is critical
but so those are the five changes that
we've seen none of them seem to be that
advantageous for sleep but the fourth
point that i mentioned which was orexin
which is this wake promoting chemical
and a good demonstration or a very sad
demonstration of its power is when it
becomes very deficient in the brain and
it leads to a condition called
narcolepsy
where you know you
you're just unpredictable with your
sleep and you um so
um
so erection when it's in high
concentrations keeps you awake when you
lose it it can you know it can put you
very much into a state of narcolepsy
where you're sleeping a lot of the time
in unpredictable sleep
why on earth when you are fasting
with the brain release awake promoting
chemical
and our answer is right now is the
following the one of the few times that
i mentioned before that we see animals
undergoing
insufficient sleep or
prolonged sleep deprivation is under
conditions of starvation
and
that is an extreme
evolutionary pressure and at that point
the brain will forego some it won't
forego all but it will forego some of
its sleep
and the reason is so that it can stay
awake for longer because the sign of
starvation is saying to the brain you
can't find food in your normal foraging
perimeter you need to stay awake for
longer so you can travel outside of your
perimeter for a fur further distance and
maybe you will find food and save the
organism
so in other words when we fast
it's giving our brain this evolutionary
signal that you are under conditions of
starvation so the brain responds by
saying oh my goodness i need to release
the chemical that helps the organism
stay awake for longer which is a raxiom
so that they can forage for more food
now of course your brain from an
evolutionary perspective doesn't know
about this thing called safeway
that you could easily go to and break
the fast
but that's how we understand fasting and
i think you know
my dear friend peter tier has um has
done a lot of work in this area too i
think fasting and david sinclair is
brilliant work goodness me what an
individual too
the work is pretty clear there that you
know time restricted eating and fasting
have
wonderful health benefits time you know
fasting is
creates this thing called hermesis
just like exercise and
low level stress and sauna heat shock um
and hormesis is a biological process i
think as david sinclair has once said in
simple layman's terms is what what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
and i think the
there is certainly good data that
fasting and time-restricted eating has
many benefits is sleep one of them it
doesn't seem to be it doesn't seem to
enhance sleep
but it's interesting to to
understand its effects on sleep i've um
like i've fasted
it's a study of nf2 i've once fasted 72
hours and another time 48 hours
and
i found that i got much less sleep and
was very restful though
i hesitate to say this but this is how i
felt which is i needed less sleep
i wonder if my brain is deceiving me
because it feels like i'm getting
a whole extra amount of focus
for free
and
i wonder if there's long-term impacts of
that because if i fast 24 hours
get the same amount of calories one meal
a day
there's a little bit of discomfort like
just uh maybe your body gets a little
bit colder
maybe there's just i mean
hunger
but the amount of
focus is crazy yeah and so i wonder it's
like i'm a little suspicious of that i
feel like i'm getting something for free
it's i'm the same way with sweetener
like uh splenda or something it's like
it's got to be really bad for you right
because why is it so tasty right and i
think yeah
as we said
for with biology
you know if there's freeze again there's
yeah there's often a cost too so
but
we at least understand the biological
basis of what you're describing it's not
that
you you actually don't need less sleep
it's that this chemical is present that
forces you more awake and so
subjectively you feel as though i don't
need as much sleep because i'm wide
awake
and those two things are quite different
it's not as though you your sleep need
has decreased it's that your brain has
hit the overdrive switch the overboost
switch to say we need to keep you awake
because food is in short supply
so you mentioned uh during sleep there's
assimilation all those kinds of things
for learning purposes but there's also
these uh you mentioned the five ways in
which we become psychotic in dreams
what do you think
what do you think dreams are about
what
why do you think we dream what
place do we go to when we dream
and why are they useful not just um not
just the assimilation aspect but just
like all the crazy visuals that we get
with dreams is there something uh
you can speak to that's actually useful
like why we have such fun
experiences in that dream world
so
one of the
camps in the sleep field is that dreams
are meaningless
that they are an epi phenomenal
byproduct of this thing called rem sleep
from which dreams come from as a
physiological state
so
the analogy would be
let's think of a light bulb
that the reason that you create the
apparatus of a light bulb is to produce
this thing called light in the same way
that we we've evolved to this thing
called rem sleep to serve whatever
functions rem sleep
but it turns out that when you create
light in that way you also produce
something called heat
it was never the reason that you
designed the light bulb it's just what
happens when you create light in that
way
and the belief so too was that dreaming
was essentially the heat of the light
bulb
that
rem sleep is critical but when you have
rem sleep with a complex brain like ours
you also produce this conscious epi
phenomenon called dreaming
i don't believe that for a second
uh i and from a simple perspective is
that i suspect that dreaming is more
metabolically costly as a conscious
experience than not dreaming so you
could still have rem sleep but
absent the conscious experience of
dreaming was probably less metabolically
costly and whenever mother nature burns
the energy unit called atp which is the
most valuable thing
there's usually a reason for it so if
what if it's more energetically
demanding
then i suspect that there is a function
to it and we've now since discovered
that dreams have a function the first as
we mentioned creativity the second is
that dreams provide a form of overnight
therapy
dreaming is a form of emotional first
aid
and it's during dream sleep at night
that we take these difficult painful
experiences that we've had during the
day sometimes traumatic
and dream sleep acts almost like a
nocturnal soothing balm
and it sort of just takes the sharp
edges off those difficult painful
experiences
so that you come back the next day
and you feel better
about them
and so i think in that sense dreaming
it's not time that heals all wounds it's
time during dream sleep that provides
emotional convalescence
so dreaming is almost a form of you know
emotional windscreen wipers
and i think
and by the way it's not just
that you dream
it's what you dream about that also
matters
so for example scientists have done
studies with learning and memory where
they
have people learn a virtual maze
and what they discovered was that
those people who then
dreamed but dreamed of the maze were the
only ones who when they woke up ended up
being better at navigating the maze
whereas those people who dreamed but
didn't dream about the maze itself they
were no better at navigating the maze so
it's not just that you it's not it's
sort of necessary but not sufficient
it's necessary that you dream but it's
not sufficient to produce the benefit
you have to be dreaming about certain
things itself and the same is true for
mental health
what we've discovered is that people who
are going through a very difficult
experience a trauma for example a very
painful divorce
those people who are dreaming but
dreaming of that difficult event itself
they go on to gain resolution to their
clinical depression one year later
whereas people who were dreaming
just as much but not dreaming about the
trauma itself did not go on to gain as
much clinical resolution to their
depression
so
it
i think to me those are the lines of
evidence that tell me dreaming is not
epi phenomenal and it's not just about
the act of dreaming it's about the
content
of the dreams not just
the fact of a dream itself it's first of
all it's fascinating it makes a lot of
sense but then immediately takes my mind
to
from an engineering perspective how that
could be useful in for example ai
systems
of uh
if you think about dreaming as a
important part about learning and
cognition and
filtering previous memories of what's
important integrating them
you know maybe you can correct me but i
see dreaming is a kind of simulation of
worlds
that are not constrained by physics
so like you you get a chance to take
some of your memories some of your
thoughts on your anxieties
and play with them
like construct virtual worlds and see
how it evolves
like to to play with those worlds in a
safe environment of your mind
safe in quotes because you can probably
get into a lot of trouble with
what the places your mind will go but
in
um this this this definitely is applied
in much cruder ways in artificial
intelligence so
one context in which this is applied is
uh
the process called uh self-play
which is uh reinforcement learning
where uh agents play against
it's itself or versions of itself and
it's all simulated of trying different
versions of themselves and playing
against each other to see
what ends up being a good
the ultimate goal is to learn um
a function that represents what is good
and what is not good in terms of how you
should act right you create a set of
decision weights based on experience and
you constantly update those weights
based on ongoing learning but the the
experience is artificially created
versus actual
real data so that's
it's a crude approximation what dreams
are which is you're hallucinating a lot
of things
to see which things are actually no i
think it's and it's been a theory that's
been put forward which is that dreaming
is a virtual reality test space that is
largely consequence-free
what an incredible gift to give a
conscious mind each and every night
now the the conscious mind the human
mind is very good at constructing dreams
that are nevertheless useful for you
like they're they're wild and crazy but
they're such that they are still
grounded in reality
to a degree where anything you learn in
dreams might be useful in reality this
is a very difficult thing to do
because it requires a lot of
intelligence that requires consciousness
uh this has been effectively recently
been used in uh self-supervised learning
for uh computer vision
with the with the process of what's
called data augmentation is that's a
very crude version of dreams which is
you take data and you mess with it
and
learn you start to learn how a picture
of a cat
truly represents a cat by messing with
it in different ways
now the crude methods currently are
cropping rotating distorting all that
kind of stuff but you can imagine much
more complicated
generative processes that start
hallucinating different cats in order
for you to understand deeply of what it
means
for something to look like a cat right
what is the prototype of the archetype
of the cat the archetype i mean that's a
very difficult process for computer
vision to
you know to go from what are the pixels
that are usually associated with the cat
to like
what is a cat in the visual space in the
three-dimensional visual space that is
projected on an image on a
two-dimensional image
what is a cat
those are like fundamentally
philosophical questions that we humans
don't know the answer to
like linguistically but when we look at
a picture of a cat and a dog
we can usually tell pretty damn well
what's the difference right and i don't
know what what that is because you can't
reduce that to pointy ears or non-pointy
ears
furry or not furries yeah about the eyes
it's been a long-standing issue in
cognitive science cognitive neuroscience
too
it's how how does the brain create
an archetype how does it create schemas
that are have general applicability
um but yet still obtain specificity
that's a very difficult
challenge we can do it we do it it's
yeah rather bloody amazing it seems like
part of the toolbox is this controlled
hallucination which is dreams
well it's a relaxing of the rigid
constraints you know i often think of
dreaming as
you know it's from an information
processing standpoint
you know the prison guards are away and
the prisoners are running a mark in a
delightful way and part of the reason is
because when you go into dream sleep the
rational part of your brain called the
prefrontal cortex which is the part it's
like the ceo of the brain it's very good
at making high-level rational top-down
decisions and controlled actions
that part of the brain is shut down
during rem sleep
but then emotional centers memory
centers visual centers motoric centers
all of those centers actually become
more active in fact some of them are
more active
than when we're awake
in the dream state that's fascinating so
your brain from a neural architecture
perspective is radically different
its network feature is
not the same as wakefulness and i think
this is
an immensely beneficial thing
that we have at least two different
rational and irrational conscious states
that we do information processing in the
rational the veritical the page one of
the google search is wakefulness
the more irrational illogical
hyperassociative google page 20 is the
rem sleep both i think are critical both
are necessary that's fascinating and
again fascinating to see how that could
be integrated in the machines to to help
them learn better
and to uh
to reason better
and in some ways we also know it from a
chemical perspective too when you go
into dream sleep it is a neurochemical
cocktail like no other that we see in
the at the rest of the 24-hour state
there is a chemical called noradrenaline
or norepinephrine in the brain
and you know of its cystic chemical in
the body called adrenaline
but upstairs in the brain noradrenaline
is very good at creating a very
hyper-focused attentive
narrow
it's sort of
very
convergent way of thinking to a point
sharp
focus that's the only thing the
spotlight of consciousness is very
narrow that's noradrenaline
when you
remove noradrenaline then you go from a
high snr a high signal to noise ratio
where it's just you and i in this moment
i don't even know what's going on
elsewhere i am with you
nor adrenaline is present
but
when you go into rem sleep it is the
only time during the 24-hour period
where your brain is devoid of any
noradrenaline it is completely shut off
and so the signal-to-noise ratio is very
different it's almost as though we're
injecting a greater amount of noise into
the neural architecture of the brain
during dream sleep as if it's chemically
brute forced into this relaxed
associative memory processing state and
then from an anatomical perspective just
as i described the prefrontal cortex
goes down
and other regions light up
so it is a state that seems to be very i
mean if you were to show me a brain scan
of rem sleep and and tell me that it's
not rem sleep just say look based on the
pattern of this brain activity what
would you say is going on in this
person's mind i would say well they're
probably not rational they're probably
not having logical thought because their
prefrontal cortex is down they're
probably feeling very emotional because
their amygdala is is active which is an
emotional center of the brain they're
definitely going to be thinking visually
because the back of the brain is lit up
the visual cortex it's probably going to
be filled with past experience
and autobiographical memories because
their
their memory centers are lighting up and
there's probably going to be movement
because their motor cortex is very
active
that to me sounds very much like a dream
and it that's exactly what we see in
brain scanners when we put people inside
of them
one of the things i
notice
sleep effects is uh my ability to see
the beauty in the world
yeah so
um
what do you think is the connection
between sleep in your emotional life
your ability to love other human beings
and love
life
yeah
i think it's
it's very
powerful and strong so
we've done a lot of work in the field of
sleep and emotion and sleeping moods and
you can separate your emotions into two
main buckets
um you know positive and negative
and what's interesting is that when you
are sleep deprived and the more hours
that you go into being awake and the few
hours that you've had to sleep
your
your negative mood starts to increase
and and we we know which individual
types of
emotions are changing i've got a
wonderful um postdoc in my lab called
etti ben simon who's doing some
incredible work on
trying to understand the emotional
individual emotional tapestry
of affective
meltdown
when you're not getting sufficient sleep
but let's just keep with two dimensions
positive and negative yes
the negative most people would think
well it's the negative that takes the
biggest hit when i'm sleep deprived it's
not
by probably in a log order magnitude
larger
is a hit on your positive emotions
in other words you stop
gaining pleasure from normally
pleasurable things and it's a state that
we call anhedonia
and anhedonia
is the state that we often call
depression so depression
to most people's surprise isn't
necessarily that you're
always feeling negative emotions it's
often more about the fact that you lose
the pleasure in the good things in life
that's what we call anhedonia that's
what we see in sleep
and insufficient sleep and it happens
quite quickly yeah it's kind of
fascinating i um
i think i do
it's not depression but like it's uh
it's a stroll into that direction which
is when i'm sleep deprived i stopped
being able to see the meaning in life
the things that gave me meanings starts
to lose meaning like stupid i it makes
me realize how enjoyable everything is
in my life because when i start to lose
it when i'm severely sleep deprived you
start to see how much life sucks when
you lose it but that said when i'm just
cognizant enough that like sleep fixes
all that so i use those states for what
they're worth in fact i personally
like to pay attention to the things that
uh
bother me in during that time
because they also reveal
important information to me
yeah i mean there's so i i find this
when i fast combined with sleep
deprivation
i am clear to see with people
clear and identifying the things that
are not going right in my life
or um
people that i'm working with are not
doing as good of a job as they could be
doing
um like
people that are negative
uh in my life i'm more able to identify
them so i don't act on that it's a very
bad time to act on those decisions but
you get quite well made recording
recording that information
because i usually when i'm well rested
and happy i see the beauty in everybody
which can get you into trouble
so yeah you have to balance those two
things but yes it's fascinating there's
an irony there too which is the fact
that you know when you're well rested
and well slept just as you said you see
the the beauty in life and it sort of
enlivens you and
sort of gives you a
quality of of life that's emotionally
very different
yet then
we are
contrasting that against the need for
not getting enough sleep because of the
beautiful things that you want to
accomplish in life
and i don't actually see them as
you know sort of completely
counter-intuitive or paradoxical because
i still think that you can strive for
all of the brilliant things that you are
striving for to have the monumental
goals the herculean challenges that you
wish to take on and solve
they can still enthrall you and excite
you and stimulate you
but
because of the insufficient sleep that
they can or that
goal can produce
it will shave off
the beauty of life that you experience
in between and again this is just about
the trade-off i will say though that and
this is not um
applicable to your circumstance um
we do know that insufficient sleep
is very strongly linked to suicide
ideation
suicide attempts
and tragically suicide completion as
well
and in fact in 20 years of studying
sleep
we have not been able to discover a
single psychiatric condition in which
sleep is normal
and i think that that is a profound
state i think it tells us so much
about
the role of sleep as a potential causal
agent in psychiatric conditions i also
think it's a potential
sign that we should be using sleep as a
tool yeah for the prevention of grave
mental illness yeah it's both a cause
and
and a solution so yeah i i mean me
personally i've gone through a few dark
periods
up quite recently and it was almost
always sleep is not the cause
but sleep is the catalyst from going to
a bad time to a very bad time
yeah and so it's it's
definitely true and it's funny how sleep
can just cure all of that there's
actually a beautiful quote by an
american entrepreneur called e joseph
kosman
who once said that the best bridge
between despair and hope is a good
night's sleep
and i spill
so much ink and hundreds of pages
inelegantly trying to say the same thing
in my book
and he said it in one line and
it's beautiful what do you think is uh
we've been talking about how to extend
this life how to make it a good life
i've been talking about uh
love
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole ride of life of life why do we
want to make it
a good one do you think there's a
meaning do you think there's a answer to
the why
for me personally
i think
the meaning of life is
is to eat is to sleep
is to fall in love
is to cry
and then to die
oh and probably race cars in between
race cars well there's a whole topic of
uh sex we didn't talk about so that's
probably in there so should we do that
we'll maybe if you'll have me back yeah
that's the following i will give around
next time we will do another three hours
on sex alone has it been yeah
it has been uh it's been over three
hours gosh okay matt i i'm a big fan of
your work i think you're doing really
important work even despite all the
things i've been saying about the
madness of my own sleep schedule i think
you're helping millions of people so
it's an honor that you spend your
valuable time
with me and i can't wait until
uh your podcast comes out i'm a huge fan
of podcast i'm a huge fan of you and
it's just an honor
to know you and to get a chance
hopefully in the future to work together
with you you're a brilliant man and
you're doing amazing things
and
i feel
immensely honored to have
met you to now know you and um to start
calling you a friend thank you for what
you do for the world and
um
for me included
thank you matt take care
thanks for listening to this
conversation with matt walker and thank
you to stamps.com
squarespace athletic greens betterhelp
and on it check them out in the
description to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from nikola tesla who we discussed in
this podcast as sleeping very few hours
a night
all that was great in the past was
ridiculed condemned combatted and
suppressed only to emerge all the more
powerfully
all the more triumphantly from the
struggle
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you